WE'RE GOING TO GET STARTED WITH
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA'S LET HIM KANEMI
ENDED WATER GARCIA AND I WILL
BE CHAIRING THIS FIRST HEARING
IT'S A- PLEASURE TO HAVE
EVERYONE. WATCHING IN VIRTUALLY
BEFORE WE GET STARTED WITH THE
HEARING I'D LIKE TO GO OVER
SOME HOUSEKEEPING RULES AS IT
RELATES TO- THE GATHERING HERE
TODAY AND SOME OF THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR THOSE THAT ARE
WITH US PHYSICALLY THOSE.
TELECONFERENCING AND THOSE JUST
WATCHING AND THEY MAY WANT TO
CALL THEM- I WILL BEGIN BY
SHARING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STEPS WE'RE TAKING TO ENSURE
EVERYONE SAFETY HERE. AND THE
PUBLIC ALSO HAS ACCESS TO THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY. DUE TO THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS I CAN PHYSICALLY BE
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO
ENSURE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MEDIA. HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
PROCEEDING WE ARE ENSURING
THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS TO
SERVE AND PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING. TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON VIA THE
PHONE OR VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE
IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN OF THE
CAPITAL OR READ SYSTEM ON THE
STATION IN THE CAPITAL PART.
EVERYONE IN THE CAPITAL MUST
WEAR MASKS THIS INCLUDES HERE
IN THAT ROOM AND KEEP THAT
WE'RE IN- AT THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM- THAT APPLIES
AS WELL IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE. FOR
YOU SIMILARLY EVERYONE
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING ROOM
OR THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATIONS IS REQUIRED TO
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING
FORTY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
ARE REQUIRING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SCENE. PLEASE FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS OF OUR SERGEANTS AND
ANY POSTED GUIDANCE IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IS ON THE AGENDA TO TEST A
FAR WOULD LIKE. TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOUR CALL MEN
PLEASE BE SURE. START SEXUAL
GENDER I WILL ASK YOU TO A THE
MICROPHONE AT THE PROPER TIME.
I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TO
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING. AND WILL
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE. TO ALSO OBSERVES PHYSICAL
DISTANCING WHEN LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. IN ADDITION TO
TESTIFYING FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. MAKE USE
OF THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS OR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM FOR
THIS HEARING IS LOCATED IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREENS IN THE ROOM SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE.
AND ASK QUESTIONS OF THESE
WITNESSES WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANYONE CAN
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THE
END OF THE AGENDA THE NUMBERTO
CALL IN AT TO THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
PIN NUMBER IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL. AND
ON YOUR TV SCREEN PLEASE CALL
WHEN YOU HAVE HEARD FROM THE
LAST WITNESS ON THE AGENDA. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE BE SURE TO
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND ALL
SMART DEVICES. TO REDUCE SOUND
ISSUES IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS YOU CAN CALL THE
SELECT COMMITTEE OFFICE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO FIVE SIX THERE WILL BE
STAFF THERE TO ASSIST YOU. FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND GET OUR ATTENTION
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE AND WE
WILL. ADDRESS YOU ACCORDINGLY.
WE WANT TO ALSO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING SOME DISRUPTIONS.
ON OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
ON THE FLOOR PROCEEDINGS THE
LAST FEW WEEKS WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO HOLD
DISCRETION. TO BE ABLE TO ASK
YOU TO BE REMOVED- IN THE CASE
THAT THE DISRUPTION CONTINUES.
IF ANY INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS THE
HEARING WE WILL DIRECT THE
SERGEANTS OUGHT TO REMOVE THEM.
OUT WITH THAT ALL LOVE START
SOME OPENING REMARKS FOR THE
HEARING- WHAT WE HAVE GONE OVER
ALL OF OUR LOGISTICS I WANT TO
WELCOME OUR WITNESSES TO THE
HEARING. AND THANK THEM FOR
COMING BEFORE THE SELECT
COMMITTEE TO GIVE US AN
INTRODUCTION TO LET THE- AND
IT'S OPPORTUNITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A STATE
TRANSITIONS TO CLEAN ENERGY AND
ITS ECONOMY THE DEMAND FOR
LITHIUM IS PROJECTED TO GROW
EXPONENTIALLY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE AND BEYOND. HOWEVER
TODAY ONLY ABOUT 1% OF LITHIUM
PRODUCTION COME FROM THE UNITED
STATES. MOST OF OUR SUPPLY COME
FROM CHINA CHILE ARGENTINA AND
AUSTRALIA. AND THIS CARRIES
ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS
ESPECIALLY FOR DOMESTIC BATTERY
MANUFACTURING. AND THE AUTO
INDUSTRY. RIGHT HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
COMPETITIVE PLAYER IN THE WORLD
LET HIM MARKET. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION THE SALTON SEA
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCE AREA. WHICH
IS NOW GOING TO AS LITTLE
VALLEY HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
MEET 40% OF THE GLOBAL LITHIUM
DEMAND. DEVELOPING LYDIA VALLEY
IN WILL SUPPORT SALTON SEA
CLEAN UP AND CREATE NEW BATTERY
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRIES THE
DRIVE INVESTMENTS AND JOB
GROWTH IMPERIAL COUNTY ONE OF
THE MOST ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED REGIONS IN THE
STATE. RECOGNIZING THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN LAST YEAR WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE LITHIUM VALLEY
COMMISSION WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
TO EXPLORE STRATEGIES THAT WILL
DEVELOP THIS EMERGING INDUSTRY.
IN CONTINUATION OF THESE
EFFORTS THIS SELECT COMMITTEE
WILL SERVE AS A COMPLIMENT
TERRY VENUE FOR DISCUSSING A
VARIETY. OF POLICY MATTERS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME FROM
THE COMMISSION'S REPORT. AGAIN
I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY WE HEAR IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD SUSTAINABLE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE BATTERY SUPPLY CHAIN
THAT IS RADICALLY DIFFERENT
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
WORLD. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN IT UP FOR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT WISH TO
MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS. IT
HAS THE ONLY OTHER COMMITTEE
PERSON HERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS THANK YOU
FOR POINTING ME TO THIS
COMMITTEE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE PRESENTATION BECAUSE
LITHIUM IS GOING TO BE THE NEXT
BIG BONE EXPECTING CALIFORNIA
FORGET IT'S THERE. BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO SUPPLY THE
LITHIUM FOR THE BATTERIES
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
POSSIBLY THE WORLD SORT OF LOOK
FOR THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW WE
WILL HAVE COLLEAGUES COMING IN
AND OUT OF THE HEARING- BUT
WE'RE CERTAINLY EXCITED TO
HAVE. A STELLAR SAID OF
PRESENTERS TODAY ADD TO OUR
FIRST PANEL. THE ROLE OF
LITHIUM CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
TRANSPORTATION AND ECONOMIC
FUTURE. IS CONSISTENT- DAVID
HOLMES WHO SHALL CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
WHAT THE GOOSE MON COMMISSIONER
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND TRYING TO PUT A SENIOR
ADVISER A BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. OF BUSINESS-AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT KNOWN
AS KOBE SO WE'LL BEGIN. WITH
OUR FIRST PRESENTER AND THAT IS
THAT CHAIR HOLD SHALL- FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
WELCOME. WELL GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
YOU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR- DIGITAL TOGETHER WITH
YOUR COLLEAGUES TO PASS THE-
THIRTY DOLLAR COMMISSION. LAW
THAT HAS ENABLED US TO GET UP
AND RUNNING HAPPY TO SHARE WE
ARE UP AND RUNNING ALL FOURTEEN
MEMBERS ARE ON BOARD DID A
GREAT JOB- STILL BE PONDS HAS
BEEN ELECTED CHURCHES DO A
TERRIFIC. BOB AND I REALLY FEEL
IT OUT WITH MY TO THAT AFRICAN
PROBERT PROVERB IF YOU. WANT TO
GO QUICKLY GO ALONE IF YOU WANT
TO GO FAR GO TOGETHER AND WE
WANT TO GO FAR AND I REALLY
FEEL OF THE DIVERSITY THAT WE
HAVE. ON THIS COMMISSION PEOPLE
REPRESENT ASSAULTS EITHER. LET
HIM RECOVERY INDUSTRY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TRIBES LEAD TO
REPRESENTATION FROM TRIBAL
NATIONS ARE AND OTHERS YOU KNOW
THIS IS REALLY THE PROCESS-
THAT WE WANT. IT'S INCLUSIVE
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE VERY MINDFUL.
GOING INTO THIS THAT. YEAH IT'S-
INDUSTRY THAT HAVE A VERY-
TEMUJIN IMPACT ON ME COMMUTERS
THE WORLD WE WANT TO. A VERY
THAT I THINK CAN DO IT. MUCH
BETTER AND DIFFERENTLY- IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE NAY OF THIS MAY-
WHICH- ALLOWS FOR OF WHAT WILL
BE BY FAR THE GREATEST WAY TO
THE COVERED. THAT EXIST IN THE
WORLD- BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
RESOURCE IN THIS. SABRINA BRYAN
ALLOWS IT TO BE RECOVERED. WHAT
OUR VIRTUALLY ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. WILL REALLY EXCITED
THAT REASON AS YOU OUTLINED
NINETY FIVE PERCENT. OF LITHIUM
TODAY IS PRODUCED IN CHILE
ARGENTINA AUSTRALIA AND CHINA.
BUT WE HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE
GEOGRAPHIC GOOD FORTUNE. TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA A WORLD LEADER
ON THIS AND SO WE DON'T CONTROL
THE RESOURCE- THE FACT WE HAVE
IT'S JUST GOOD FORTUNE BUT WE
DO CONTROL WE DO ABOUT IT
THAT'S WHAT THIS PROCESS IS
ABOUT SO. I WANT TO JUST BEGIN
BY GIVING A LITTLE BIT OF AN
OVERVIEW- AND- WHERE THIS FITS
IN SO YOU KNOW WE THINK ABOUT
LIVING I THINK THE BEST WAY TO
UNDERSTAND IT. IS TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT IT AS THE OIL OF
THE CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. IT IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO EVERYTHING WE'RE
DOING OBVIOUSLY- ELECTRIC CARS
PARKED ARE SKYROCKETING NOW
IT'S NOT JUST GOOD. TESLA IS
THE MOST NOTABLE CAR CAN BE THE
WORLD'S OF MORE VALUABLE THE
NEXT. THREE BIGGEST- IN IN THE
U. S. BUT ALSO JUST IF YOU LOOK
AT THE TRENDS I MEAN EVEN
YESTERDAY. FORD ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO INCREASE
INVESTMENT. IN VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION TWENTY TWO
BILLION BY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TO TWENTY FIVE. YEAH DOES
THAT INCREASE THEIR STOCK PRICE
WENT UP 8% THE MARKET IS
ADVANTAGES. ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INVESTMENTS BECAUSE IT SEEMS
THAT IS THE FUTURE AND- THIS IS
A GOOD SIGN EVERY MAJOR CAR
COMPANY AROUND THE WORLD IS
INVESTING ELECTRIC. IN AND DAY
OUT IN CALIFORNIA TODAY WORKED
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND SOLD
WE'RE ADDING SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES A DAY. AND
LAST YEAR AS YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN. ELECTRIC VEHICLES
BECAME THE NUMBER ONE EXPORT
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THIRTY FOUR MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES. MAKING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES- INCLUDING ELECTRIC
BUSES COMPANIES LIKE. PROTERRA
B. Y. D. OR SELLING ELECTRIC
BUSES TO FORTY STATES. AROUND
THE COUNTRY MANUFACTURED HERE
TO THIS IS GROWING. BEYOND OUT
WE WANT THE DIVISION WE LIVED
IN. VALLEY IS REALLY TO. COME
PLEAD THAT COOL LITHIUM
ECOSYSTEM WE WILL TO DO. HIM
HERE AT. ENVIRONMENT WITH WAY
HOW OF. LIKE THE VEHICLE AS
WELL AS IN A STORAGE ENTITIES
TO ALL IT'S KIND. AS POINT OUT.
THIS YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHERE DO A TEN FOR INCREASE. OF
ENERGY STORAGE ON THE GRID
BEING PROCURED BY THE YOU TELL.
AND THE HIGH THE METER GROWING
AS WE HAVE THOUSAND. BEHIND THE
METER ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS
PRETTY MUCH ALL THE LITHIUM
ION. AND WE'RE ADDING ABOUT
FORTY NEW ONCE A DAY AT THE
RATE OF INCREASE IS GROWING SO.
BUT WHAT IS NOT IN PLACE SO WE
GOTTA GET TO SKILLS THE LITHIUM
RECOVERY. THAT SKILL ITSELF.
AND THEN. THAT REMAIN. AND TOP
BY THAT WE WANT TO BUILD ALL
THAT. SO IT CAN BE AND TELL-
IT'S I DID SPEND A LOT OF TIME.
WITH BATTERY MANUFACTURERS ARE
LOOKING TO OPEN A FACILITIES IN
IN CALIFORNIA'S AS THOSE WHO
ALREADY HAVE. JOBS LIKE YOU
KNOW BATES AND QUANTUM SCAPE
AND CN'S AND SPARKS AND OTHERS-
AND THAT'S ALL PART OF THIS.
THIS PROCESS IS LOOKING DOWN
THE COMMISSION IS GOING TO BE-
GETTING INTO IT WILL BE
DELIVERED IN THE REPORT AS YOU
KNOW- NEXT YEAR- I DID ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT YOU KNOW AS
WE ARE. PUSHING THE RECOVERY OF
LITHIUM THIS IS ALL IN SUPPORT
AS WELL OF THE GREETING
ELECTRIC GRIDS ALL THESE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES- THAT ARE
COMING ONLINE ARE. GETTING
POWERED BY THE GREED THAT IS
INCREASINGLY QUICK LAST YEAR-
THE 202063% OF THE ELECTRICITY
ON THE GRID IN CALIFORNIA CAME
FROM CARBON FREE SOURCES. WE
ARE ON ROUTE 2100% THE BY
DEMONSTRATION HAS MADE THAT
NOW. THE NATIONAL GOAL AND I
WANT TO GIVE THAT YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR. THE SUPPORT OF
SB ONE HUNDRED DOT TWO AND A
HALF YEARS AGO THAT'S REALLY
BECOME. THE TEMPLATE AND I'M
HAPPY TO SAY- JUST YESTERDAY.
WE COMPLETED FOUR YEARS OF WORK
ON OFFSHORE WIND GETTING A
DEAL. WITH DEPARTMENT INTERIOR
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE- TOWARDS
THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED ON
OFFSHORE WIND WHICH WILL.
FURTHER HELP SUPPORT OUT OF THE
GREEN AGREED. TOGETHER WITH ALL
THESE OTHER TERRIFIC RESOURCES.
LIKE- GEOTHERMAL. ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE WANT
TO. IN THE LISTING ACROSS. IT
IS. A GOOD. OF ENERGY SOURCE
AND- GEOTHERMAL GEOTHERMAL
PLAYS IN A- AND- ROLE.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU REMEMBER
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE RETIRING.
DIABLO CANYON WHICH IS THE LAST
REMAINING NUCLEAR PLANT IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE MINUTES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
RESOURCE. GEOTHERMAL IS ALSO
20% RESOURCE ON LIKE SOLAR AND
WIND AND SO. ONE OF THE
DYNAMICS THAT I FIND VERY
COMPACT COMPELLING EXCITING
ABOUT. THE RECOVERY SAID ADDED
REVENUE STREAM THAT CAN HELP
MAKE. OUR GEOTHERMAL POWER
PLANTS- MORE COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER TO HOPEFULLY SUPPORT SO
MORE INVESTMENT AND GROWTH AND
EXPANSION IN THAT SECTOR WHICH
IS GOOD FOR AGREED. AS WELL SO.
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT IN THIS
HOLISTIC. ON AND INCLUSIVELY
YEAH THIS IS A HELLO JOURNEY I
WANT TO JUST. GET MY THINKS
WELL. WHAT'S THAT HE'S BEEN
TERRIFIC ADDITION TO THE LOOK
DOG IT'S VERY COMMON. AS WELL
TO LIFT UP THIS COMMUNITY THE
SALTON SEA VALLEY AS WE MOVE-
YEAH THERE SOME EXCITED
DISCUSSION HAPPENING THAT'S WHY
ABOUT. SOME OF FUNDING THE BE
ATTACK- YOU KNOW HE'S WERE
RELUCTANT COVER THEIR GO TO.
THE RESTAURANT SOLVE AND
COMPETITIVE THE COMMUNITY- LET
ME LET ME JUST WRAP UP WITH
TWO. REQUESTS FOR CONSIDERING.
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THE FIRST
IS YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS
PROGRAM WHICH WE'VE HAD FOR
ALMOST FORTY YEARS CALLED.
GREATER. WHICH IS THE
GEOTHERMAL. RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT WHICH GET PER. OF
THE- FROM LEASES ON FOR LANDS
THAT ARE THESE TWO GEOTHERMAL
SO THERE'S ABOUT A DOZEN.
GENERAL POWER PLANTS IN THE
SALTY PRINCIPLE. WE TAKE THAT
MONEY WHICH IS NOT MUCH IT'S
MAYBE A MILLION OR TWO A YEAR
IT COMES IN BUT WE REPURPOSE IT
OUT IN GRANTS TO. SUPPORT
GENERALLY- GEOTHERMAL AND BUT
THE RELATED TO GEOTHERMAL
ACTIVITIES. THERE IS A
CONSTRAINT ON THE FACT THAT WE
LIKE TO SEE LIFTED- AND WE HAVE
A PROPOSAL INTO THE LEGISLATURE
ON THAT AND I WOULD JUST ALLOWS
GREATER FLEXIBILITY I'M VERY
INTERESTED TO. FOCUS RECUERDA
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE-
TO BETTER SUPPORT A LISTING OF
DEPARTMENTS SO THAT PROPOSALS
FOR YOU- AND I THINK ALL
TOGETHER NOW OKAY ENERGY
COMMISSION WE CLING TO THE NEXT
SIXTEEN MILLION. FOR LITHIUM
ARE DEVELOPED SOMETHING THAT
CAN BRING SOME OF THAT FROM.
TECH BUT THAT'S ONE THING SO
MANY OTHERS JUST BIG PICTURE
AROUND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- I
CAN REALLY ONLY SPEAK TO THE
TWO POINT ONE BILLION. IN THE
MANDATE REGARDLESS- FOR THE
ENERGY COMMISSION BUT WE'RE NOT
SPENT ABOUT HALF OF THAT MONEY.
ON IN- TRANSPORTATION LECTER
KITCHEN WHICH IS GOING TO
HUGELY INCREASE THE DEMAND FOR
LITHIUM LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
SO. THAT INCLUDES BUILDING OUT
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS
THE STATE WE'RE DOING ABOUT
HALF OF OUR CHARGING
INVESTMENTS. IN LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
WILL ALSO BE SUPPORTING-
THERE'S A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO SUPPORT- DURING
EUROVISION VEHICLES
MANUFACTURED ARE WHICH I THINK
ALSO FITS VERY WELL. WITH THE
RHODESIAN BEHIND WITH THE
VALLEY SO ARE ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
AS YOU CONSIDER THOSE ITEMS
THIS WILL. NOT STOP THERE. AT
TO TAKE A QUESTION THANK YOU
THANK THANK YOU CHAIR WILL GO
HEAD AND- HOLD OFF QUESTIONS TO
LAUGHTER THE LAST. AND SOUL.
HANG TIGHT THERE WILL GET BACK
TO DE HAS. QUESTIONS THAT MAKE
UP FOR YOU TO. OUR NEXT-
ANALYSTS. AND SPEAKER BE MARTHA
GOES COMMISSIONER OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION. WELCOME
THANK YOU TO GARCIA THAT COULD
HAVE MA'AM I AM WANT TO THANK
YOU INVITING ME TO I REALLY WAS
SO I MOST JUST CAN TIE A LITTLE
ABOUT THAT MAY ROLE AT THE
PEACE PLAY ON THAT. ANOTHER
THING THAT WE CAN WHICH IS ON
AT THE PROCUREMENT AND IN THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT THERMAL
PRODUCTION PLAYS RIGHT TO
ACTUALLY HEAL THE LITHIUM OF
FOR THIS EFFORT YEAH NEXT YEAR
HOPE SHE'LL MENTIONED- WE ACTED
VAULT FOR MANY YEARS WITH
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE ENERGY
NEEDS IN PARTICULAR RELATED TO
DIABLO BUT OTHER RELIABILITY
NEEDS THAT HAVE ARISEN AS WE
USED TO HAVE ALL SINCE THAT
TIME. AND JUST THIS FRIDAY. UGH
EGGMAN OFTEN A DECISION THERE'S
ACTUALLY ALSO. AN ALTERNATE HE
ISSUE. BUT OVERALL THE PROPOSED
DECISION IS RECOMMENDING THAT
THERE IS A NEED FOR ALL THE%
HELLO SERVING ENTITIES TO
PROCURE ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL MEGAWATTS
THAT'S A VERY LARGE NUMBER.
ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
THE NEW ELECTRICITE RESOURCES
TO COME ONLINE BETWEEN THE
YEARS TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THIS IS WHAT
WE CONSIDER A MID TERM
PROCUREMENT. AND AS WAS
MENTIONED RIGHT YOU'RE HOPE
SHIELDING YOURSELF- JERRY
GARCIA WE NEED TO GET TO A
HUNDRED BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE SO
THE NEEDS OF THESE TYPES OF
RESOURCES WHICH I'LL GET INTO A
LITTLE BIT. ARE REALLY CRITICAL
LOWS FOR THE MID TERM
PROCUREMENT AS WELL AS OUR LONG
TERM GOALS IT IT PASSED SINCE
IT IS INEVITABLE THAT WE WILL
DEPEND ON GEOTHERMAL TO GET
2100% TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND
REALLY THE QUESTION IS THE
TIMELINE. AND THE MIXTURE OF
THE PORTFOLIO. THIS IS A-
THERE'S A COUPLE GOALS JOB
CANYON PLACEMENT WAS ONE IN OF-COURSE GETTING TO ON TRACK AND
MAINTAINING ON TRACK 2100% BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THE BIG
COMPONENT OF THESE ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED- MAKE
LOTS IS THAT TWO THOUSAND OF
THOSE. MEGAWATTS NEED TO BE A
LONG COULD WE CONSIDER THEM TO
HAVE A LONG LEAD TIME RESOURCE
TO BE IN LINE AT THE LATER TIME
OF THAT MITCHELL PROCUREMENT
WHICH IS TWENTY TWENTY SIX- IN
THOSE TYPES OF OUR RESOURCES
OUR- RESOURCES LIKE GEOTHERMAL
BUT ALSO. LONG DURATION STORAGE
IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE. HOW FOR THE
TWO THOUSAND SO ONE THOUSAND.
MIDDLE WATCHED MUST COMFORT
ENERGY RESOURCE MATCH REALLY
THE ATTRIBUTES OF GEO THERMAL.
AND THIS IS THAT THINGS LIKE
THAT THE RESOURCE MUST BE
DISPATCHABLE THAT MUST BE FIRM
AND IT MUST HAVE THE MINIMUS
EMISSIONS ALL OF THESE ARE THE
ATTRIBUTES THE GEOTHERMAL HAS
AND CAN OFFER NOT TO MEET THIS
ONE THOUSAND MEGAWATT
REQUIREMENTS- LET'S SEE HERE. I
WAS ALSO GONNA- NOTE THAT EVEN
OF COURSE TODAY THE LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES COULDN'T SEEK
THESE CONTRACTS WITH GEOTHERMAL
PROJECTS AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- THE CCA'S
COMMITTEE CHOICE AGGREGATORS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ACTUALLY
SOME OF THE LEADING- ALEX IS
THAT ARE ENGAGING IN CONTRACTS
WITH GEOTHERMAL AND JUST LAST
NOVEMBER- WE SAW THAT HAVE NOT
RESIGNED HIS NUMBER BUT CCA'S
ARE EXPECTED TO BRING ONLINE
FOURTEEN MEGAWATTS. OF
GEOTHERMAL BY TWENTY TWENTY TO.
S. IT'S A SMALLER STAFF OF
COURSE THERE IS COURAGE UNDER
CONTRACT ADDITION BEEN TERMS OF
THE NEW CONTRACTS THAT'S ONE A
GOOD SIGN- AND IN ADDITION JUST
AS WE AS I MENTIONED THIS IS A
PROPOSED DECISION IT IS OUT FOR
COMMENT AND SO WOULD WELCOME.
OF COURSE ALL OF THE MEMBERS
THAT THE PUBLIC AS WELL TO
REALLY ENGAGE AS WE DELIBERATE
ON THE FINAL PIECE OF THIS
PROPOSED DECISION OR ANY
REFINEMENTS ARE JUST MONTHS.
AND WE ALSO WILL BE HOLDING
WHAT WE CALL AN ALL PARTY WHERE
ALL OF THE PARTIES INVOLVED
WILL HAVE THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
PUBLICLY PUSH FOR ANY
AMENDMENTS TO THE PROPOSED
DECISION- AND THEN FINALLY I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW AS SUCH-
HOPE SHE'LL MENTION THAT IT'S
REALLY BEEN. AND I WOULD
ENJOYABLE TO BE A PART OF THE
LITHIUM VALLEY COMMISSION. AND
PARTICULARLY TO SEE THE LOCAL
SHOULD REALLY FOCUS ON AS WE
DEAL WITH ALL OF THESE
ESTIMATES AND NUMBERS AND
PRODUCTION GOALS AN- EXCEPTION
THAT WE DON'T. THAT WE DO SO
WITH A COMMUNITY MEETING FIRST
AND JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT YOUR BOSS'S BEEN EXCELLENT
IN OUR FRAMING OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND- I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING AND TO
SEE WHAT PART THE COMMISSION S.
C. C. P. C. AT THE COMMISSION
COULD CONTRIBUTE. TO THE
LITHIUM BALLON COMMISSION
GOALS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMISSIONER. WILL UP AGAIN
HOLD OFF ON ANY QUESTIONS UNTIL
AFTER LAST PRESENTER- BUT I'M
SURE THERE WILL BE SOME
QUESTIONS- WILL GO ON TO OUR
NEXT UP SPEAKER AND THAT IS
KIND OF PALLADA TO YOUR VISOR
OF THE- BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT-
AND GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- PLEASE. I BEGAN.
THIS A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND TO THE NUMBER
OF SILICON VALLEY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- MY
NAME IS KIND OF PRAYER AND I'M
THE SENIOR ADVISER OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. CORDOBA'S AS YOU
MENTIONED. AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY IN THE INVITE
TO IMPROVE TO PROVIDE INPUT
INTO THIS DISCUSSION AND TO
SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING. A
DOMESTIC LITHIUM SUPPLY CHAIN
AND HOW THE STATE CAN LAY THAT
FOUNDATION. THAT TO PROMOTE
FUTURE INVESTMENTS. IN OUR AREA.
BUILDING LOOK IN SUPPLY CHAIN
PRESENTS. AN IMPERATIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. IT IS IMPERATIVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE MADE SUCH A
PROFOUND AND GLOBALLY RELEVANT
COMMITMENT TO BOTH STAFF. AND
TO A RESILIENT DECARBONISE
GREAT. BOTH OF WHICH WILL RELY
TO EVEN MORE SIGNIFICANT
EXTENT. ON THE PRODUCTION OF
LITHIUM AND MORE PARTICULARLY
LITHIUM BATTERY PRODUCTION WELL
IN EXCESS OF TODAY'S GLOBAL OUT.
THERE ARE OTHER MERGING BATTERY
CHEMISTRIES THAT ARE
INTERESTING AND RELEVANT NO WE
NEED SCALABILITY IN THE NEAR
TERM ESPECIALLY AND IN
REFERENCE TO OUR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND IT MUST BE
AFFORDABLE WHICH MEANS WE MUST
EXTRUDING EXTRACTED. A LOT OF
LIBYA. THERE IS CURRENTLY A
GLOBAL CONTEST AS WAS MENTIONED
BY THE CHAIR ON THIS EMERGING
RESOURCE AND OTHER COUNTRIES
ESPECIALLY- SOME WHICH ARE NOT
NECESSARILY CONDUCIVE TO UNITED
STATES MENTALITY AT TODAY'S
LITHIUM RESOURCES ARE EITHER
HIGHLY CONCENTRATED. OR
PRODUCED IN ENVIRONMENTALLY
DAMAGING WAYS AS CHAIR HOPE
SHE'LL MUCH. FROM AN ACCOUNTING
PERSPECTIVE. IT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SOURCES
DIRECTLY IN A MORE CONDUCIVE
MANNER- LIMITING SOME OF THE
TRANSPORTATION CONSTRUCTION
STRENGTH. AND ALSO IMPROVING-
BOTH SOURCING AND MANUFACTURING
CLOSE TO HOME WHICH GUARANTEES
NO SUPPLY FOR OUR
MANUFACTURERS. AND ALSO
REDUCING WITHIN PRODUCTION
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT. THAT
BEING SAID THIS ALSO CREATES A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY. IS AN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
CAN DELIVER ON THE INTEGRATED
BENEFITS FOR BOTH LOCAL
COMMUNITY OF THE STATE AND FOR
THE GLOBAL MARKET PLACE AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS. YEAH I'M JUST A
SECURE SUPPLY OF THESE RAW
NATURAL RESOURCES WHICH IS
ENTIRELY VALUABLE IN AND OF
THEMSELVES. CALIFORNIA CAN
NURTURE THE FULL VALUE ADDED
INDUSTRY OF BATTERY PRODUCTION
AND THOSE RELATED TECHNOLOGIES.
AND THIS IS A POTENTIAL SOURCE
FOR HIGH WAGE JOBS IN THE
FUTURE. BY WORKING WITH GLOBAL
FIRMS WERE PURSUING THE LICKING
VALLEY RESOURCE AND THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN THE
REGION CALIFORNIA CAN PARTNER
TO DEVELOP CURRICULA AND JOB
PLACEMENT STRATEGIES THAT
CREATE LOCAL PATHWAYS. TO THESE
HIGH ROAD JOBS. A CLOSE LOOP
LITHIUM EXTRACTION PROCESS
INDUSTRY IS PROMISING AND CAN
BECOME A MODEL FOR THE WORLD.
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN AND
DEVELOP A CIRCULAR ECONOMY AS
IT RELATES TO LITHIUM
PRODUCTION AND BATTERY
PRODUCTION AS WELL AS OUR
MISSION VEHICLES THIS IS
DEFINITELY NEEDED AND NEEDED TO
BE IN CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
CAN REQUIRE ENCOURAGE COMPANIES
TO PAY INTO AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REMEDIATION PLAN THAT WILL ALSO
BENEFIT THE SOLVENCY AS
CHURCHILL PENSION FOR. ANY
STRUCTURED PROPERLY THE STATE'S
ELECTRIC LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
TEMPERATURE COST EFFECTIVE YOU
THERMAL POWER FROM THE SAME
BRIAN THAT PRODUCES LITHIUM
THEREBY REDUCING OVERALL COSTS
FOR BOTH PRODUCTION OF POWER
AND THE EXTRUSION UP WITH.
ADDING A CRITICAL TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN RESOURCE. AGAIN AS GERMAN
HOPE SHE'LL MENTION SINCE WE'RE
LOSING GALA CANYON IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE- NEXT I'LL GO INTO
SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITY HOW
THESE OPPORTUNITIES ARE GOING
TO DELIVER BY GOBIZ AND THROUGH
SUPPORT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL AGENCIES COMMUNITY GROUPS
FEDERAL- WE RECOGNIZE THAT. TO
BE ABLE TO HANDLE ANYTHING OF
THIS MAGNITUDE REQUIRES A LOT
OF LOCAL SUPPORT BOTH FROM SALT
AREA COMMUNITY GROUPS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO
ACCELERATE PROJECT DEVELOPMENT
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. AND AS SUCH
OUR GOAL THIS TEAM AND AS PART
OF OUR EXPANSION THROUGH THE
REGION PRICE TOGETHER
INITIATIVE HAS IMPLEMENTED SOME
LOCAL SUPPORT MEASURES.
INCLUDING MONTHLY MEETINGS WITH
THE S. AND KERIO VALLEY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION SCHERING INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT FROM
WITHIN VALLEY ASSOCIATED
COMPANIES MANY OF WHICH WERE
MENTIONED EARLIER PATCHWORK OF
SHIELD AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
THOSE COMPANIES DIRECTLY. TO
BOTH ON CHAIN CONTRACTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. WITHIN OUR SENSE
OF PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY WORSE
COUNTY NAVIGATE UTILITY OF THE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FOR STUPID REASONS.
WITH THE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT ON A TAX RATE WILL
PARCELS MATCH- GEOTHERMAL
WEARABLES CAN SET. ADDITIONALLY
WERE WORKING WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS IBTC KAZAKH
COMPANIES AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
ON THE EXECUTION OF THAT
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT OF THE
SOUTHERN END OF POLICY TO
SUPPORT THE PROJECTOR PROJECTS
AND TO PROVIDE SOME MUCH NEEDED
INCENTIVES. FOR THESE MASSIVE
BUILD OUT. I TO FORTY COUNTY IN
CONNECTING WITH I THANK YOU
ALIVE I SURF PEROT BUILDING
WANTS YOU TO R. COMPLETED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THEIR WHILE.
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THAT WILL ENABLE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT WILL BE NECESSARY IN
SOME OF THESE AREAS AND AS SUCH
GOVERNMENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT.
HAS BEEN PROVIDED THROUGH- OUR
CONNECTIONS WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. EVERY TWO WEEKS WE
CAN BE IN STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS IN ORDER TO SHARE
UPDATES ON NOT JUST BOTH THE A
VALLEY A SEARCH BUT ALSO
BROADBAND EMISSIONS AND
ANYTHING WHICH COULD HAVE
SEVERAL GRANT OPPORTUNITIES HI
THE- AS SUCH. ALL PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO A BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION- MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HOW TO
OVERLAY TAX INCENTIVES AND
OTHER PROGRAMMATIC INCENTIVES
FOR THE PRODUCTION OF LITHIUM
AND A FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
BATTERIES- USING THE STATE'S
TOOLS AND GRANT MAKING TAX
CREDITS AND PUBLIC FINANCE.
INTEGRATION SESSION TO PROMOTE
THE STATE'S PRIORITIES FOR THE
REGION AND TO MOTIVATE PRIVATE
CAPITAL THAT IS ALIGNED WITH
OUR VALUES. AND ASSISTING
COMPANIES MOVING THROUGH
SPECIFIC INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THOSE MENTIONED BEFORE
AN INCLUSIVE OF KALKAJI THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL CAPER
AND OTHERS- WILL SERVE AS A
MECHANISM FOR CITING LARGE ON
THE DELIVERY COMPANIES WANT TO
CO LOCATE NEAR THE RESOURCE
SUCH AS THE MANUFACTURING. OF
BATTERIES FOR A ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WE FEEL THAT THESE ARE
GOOD OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE.
LARGE SCALE INVESTMENTS WHICH
AND LEAD. TO A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF JOB GROWTH
OPPORTUNITY.THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ARE YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND I'M GONNA
ASK YOU FOR ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OF. ANY OF THE PRESENTERS OF
SPOKEN. PLEASE GO NOW WITH THE
WATER THAT IT USES TO EXTRACT
THE LITHIUM WHERE'S THE WATER
GOING TO COME FROM AN- OF. THE
AREA THAT IT'S COMING FROM.
DOWN SOUTH. MANY WATERS A BIG.
WELL SHORT SUPPLY CALIFORNIA
READY. TO SEE A FIVE. CAN SPEAK
TO THAT I THINK I THINK SOME OF
THE- DEVELOPERS WILL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THE NEXT PANEL BUT- WHAT
HAPPENS IN GEOTHERMAL POWER
PLANTS AS YOU CYCLE. THE
SUPERHEATED GEOTHERMAL BRINE
WHICH IS A YOU KNOW HALF A MILE
BELOW THE SURFACE AND JUST RUNS
ON A LOOP BASICALLY AND SO THIS
PROCESS DOESN'T REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL WATER YOU'RE JUST.
TAKING DIFFERENT MOST YOU'RE
YOU'RE BASICALLY JUST CIRCLING
THE SAME PRODUCTS SUPERHEATED
BRIAN THAT. RUNS THE DIFFICULT
PART THERE'S A PROCESS TO
WITHDRAW THAT- THERE MAY BE
SOME I MEAN I THINK THERE'S
MORE DETAIL THAT OF THE DEVELOP
GETS TO- WHAT ARE INTERNATIONAL
YOUR USING THEIR- PRIVATE. IN
SERVICE OF THE CHILDREN OF OUR
PLANTS. THANK YOU. NO QUESTIONS.
TWO BUT MR BRAY YOU- DESIST
ABOUT THE COME MARKET GLOBAL
LITHIUM MARKET AS A STATE HOW
DO WE ENCOURAGE COMPANIES OR
INVESTORS TO PICK UP
CALIFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITIES-
VERSUS WHAT SEEMS TO BE. A
COMPETITOR AT TIMES IS NEVADA
WHO HAS MIGHT HAVE A SMALL.
FRACTURED OF THE LITHIUM
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT. YES THANK YOU MISTER SO
VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
SOMETHING THAT WE DEAL WITH ON
A DAILY BASIS ONE WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH COMPANIES ARE
LOOKING AT THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE PRESENTED TO THEM
THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY A VERY DIFFICULT
CALCULUS. A LOT OF IT DEALS
WITH BOTH THE LOGISTICS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND
MOVING THE GOOD THAT THEY NEED
TO PRODUCE THEIR- AND PRODUCTS
BUT ALSO THE ENDING WAS JUST AS
TO HOW THEY ACTUALLY SHIP THIS
MARKET STUFF. THEY'RE LOOKING
AT A NUMBER OF CENTERS WITH
MAYBE COST CENTERS AND IN THE
CASE OF CALIFORNIA PERSONS
ABOUT A ONE OF THE- MORE
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCES IS IN
OUR ENERGY RATES. AND AS SUCH
IF WE ARE ABLE TO EXPAND
GEOTHERMAL REDUCED RATES AND
ALSO INCREASE PRODUCTION THAT
WOULD BE. SOMETHING THAT THEY
WOULD DEFINITELY FIND TO BE
MORE VALUABLE- THAT WOULD BE
CLOSER THE RESOURCE THEREBY
ELIMINATING SOME OF THE
LOGISTICS COST AND ALSO
POTENTIALLY REDUCING SOME OF
THE BURDEN OF THE PRODUCTION-
OF OURS OUR ENERGY- WE ALSO
EXPECTS THAT COLOCATION CREATES
AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE SOME OF
THE BATTERIES MANUFACTURERS
NAGLE HQ REMANUFACTURING OR
EXCLUSION OF THE- OF THE PIECES
TO BE ABLE TO RECYCLE THOSE
GOODS AND SO WE DEPLOYED.
MARKET AND SOME CONCENTRATION
AND GOOD AND COLOCATION IS
GOING TO BE VITAL TO BOTH OF
THOSE AREAS ESPECIALLY AS YOU
TRY AND DRIVE COSTS DOWN IN
WHAT IS GOING TO BE AN EVEN
MORE COMPETITIVE. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES FACE. THANK YOU THAT'S
HOW MAY. IT CHAIR HOPE CHILD
MAYBE. WE AND THIS- BASED ON
KIND OF YOUR HANDS. THE REALLY.
TO THE LEDGE. I OF RIGHT-
LOCATION OKAY LOCATION RIGHT.
AS WITH THE LOGISTICS OF IT-
THAT CHAIR HOPE CHILD IN HIS
PRESENTATION TALKED ABOUT- DE
MULTE MULTIPLE- CONNECTIONS TO
STATE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES. AND
THE ISSUE OF. POWER GENERATION
NEEDED FOR THE LARGE
INVESTMENTS GOING INTO.
ELECTRIFICATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
MAYBE HE COULDN'T ELABORATE A
BATES AND CONNECTING THOSE
DOTS- BUILDING OFF OF YOUR
RESPONSE BECAUSE- I THINK
THERE'S SOMETHING. TO BE SAID
ABOUT. THE LOCATION THE
MULTIPLE COAL BENEFITS. OF
LOOKING VALLEYS OPPORTUNITIES-
THAT IT'S PRESENTED SO MISTER
CHAIRED WOULD YOU LIKE O. PASS
ALONG. TO TWO CASES WE CAN MAKE
FOR THESE COMPANIES AS TO WHERE
THEY LOOK AT ONE IS. OUR
PROXIMITY TO MARKETS- IF YOU
TALK TO. THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
MANUFACTURING LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO CALIFORNIA AND I FOUND. THAT
GREAT LENGTH. THAT'S ONE OF
THEIR MAJOR. THANK YOU FOR THE
LARGEST MARKET FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IN THE UNITED STATES
BY FAR ABOUT HALF THE- US
SELECTIVE VEHICLE MARKET THE
SAME IS TRUE FOR ENERGY
STORAGE. AND SO BEING CLOSE
THOSE MARKETS TO CLOSE THOSE
CUSTOMERS TO REDUCE SHIPPING
COSTS. IS A BIG ADVANTAGE IN
THAT SECONDLY IS THE HUMAN
RESOURCES YOU KNOW IN A
CREDIBLE- TALENT POOL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- IN THE REGION. THAT
THEY CAN DROP ARM. ONE IN
ADDITION I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HI
THIS. IS TAMMY DO EVERYTHING I
CAN TO SUPPORT. OTHER THING
VALLEY WITH WHICH IS- THE KEY
TO A BOARD. OF WHICH THE
TERRIBLE ACADEMICALLY CAN NOW
WE CAN SEE EXAMPLES OF. YOUR
BILL- BUT IT BASICALLY IS. THE
TRANSPLANT G. YOU KNOW
FINANCING. AUTHORITIES WE DON'T
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THE TAX
WORD ENERGY OF ALL SORTS
INCLUDING YOU'RE JUST SOME-
BETTER MANUFACTURING COULD
ANOTHER OF THE STATE ARE WE
ANNOUNCED UP TO TELL DOING OUR
BATTERIES WE WANT TO MAKE THAT
WOULD ON FOCUS STARTED WAYS I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
DOUBLING THE BUDGET MODERNIZE
TWO HUNDRED THIS YEAR. WELL I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE I THINK A
GREAT AND THAT REDUCES THE
LIMITS OF THE SALES TAX ONE
HUNDRED THAT'S IN AND- OUR
MANUFACTURING EQUIPMENT INTO
THE MOTHER OF COSTA OLD START
OF THESE ARE INDFUL OF. THANK
YOU FOR I DO HAVE A QUESTION.
FOR CHAIRS YOU HAVE A QUESTION
FOR GO MON- AND THERE TO
QUESTIONS OF ONE REVIEWED TO
THE- DIRECTION OF LOS SERVING
AS- ON CHURCH. TO PROCURE NEW.
TO MEET MADE FROM A LONG TERM
RELIABLE- PROCESSES USUALLY TO
NOT CAN THIS- THE NONSENSE
YOU'VE BEEN I REFER TO HIM AS A
THE CALL- THAT WE I CAN SEE.
FROM THESE AFTER. ONE CAN WE DO
AS A- BODY IS THE COULD. TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE COPE ARE
BEING BECAUSE- IN THE PER. OF
PROCURING- THAT'S THE FIRST THE
SECOND AS A OF. LET THE ABOUT
COMMISSION- PERHAPS YOU CAN
ELABORATE ON SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING AND I
KNOW THAT THESE ARE QUESTIONS
THAT THAT. COME UP RIGHT
RELATED TO THE WATER QUESTIONS-
BUT TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND WHAT
WHAT TYPE OF DISCUSSIONS IS THE
LET THE ABOUT THE COMMISSION
HAVING. AS IT RELATES TO. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. IMPACTS THAT-
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED WITH WHEN
THEY THINK OF PM EXTRACTION IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD VERSUS
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE MAYBE YOU
CAN. SHED SOME LIGHT HERE I
KNOW THAT IT'LL BE A QUESTIONS
THAT. COMES UP THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE. SO HEARING TODAY WITH
OTHER PANELISTS AS WELL. YES I
THINK YOU'RE A GERMAN GARCIA
I'LL TAKE A HOUSING BILLS
QUESTIONS BACKWARDS AND- MOSTLY
BECAUSE I WILL DIFFER LARGELY
TO VOTE. ARLINGTON VALUE
COMMISSION CHAIR CHAIRWOMAN
CLASS AND SHOULD BE HAVE TAKEN
LEADERSHIP OF FORMING A
COMMITTEES SO THAT WE CAN
DISCUSS THESE TOPICS AND- AND
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN A PRIORITY
FROM WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
THE COMMISSIONERS THERE. OF
MAKING WITH THAT YOU KNOW THIS
TYPE OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS
ACTUALLY A BETTER THING FOR THE
COMMUNITY BOTH ECONOMICALLY BUT
ALSO MENTALLY AND OF COURSE
HAVING- JUST SOME BACKGROUND ON
IT WE KNOW THAT HAVING A
FOOTPRINT ON THE SOUTHERN END
OF THE TWO KILLER. OF THE C.
IT'S GONNA BE A BENEFITS TO
POTENTIALLY FOR AIR QUALITY IF
WE DO ALL THIS CORRECTLY. ONLY
THE ACTOR WOMAN PASSED TO
REALLY EXPAND ON HOW WE CAN
WORK WITH COMMUNITIES AND THAT
TO REALLY ENSURE THAT ALL OF
THOSE CONCERNS. ARE BEING
ADDRESSED AT THE FRONT END. I
THE ISSUE PROCURE AT IT'S A
VERY. AS I MAY. I THINK WE NEED
TO HEAR NOW ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PERSPECTIVE
OF FOLKS WHO ARE- PROPONENTS OF
GEO THERMAL IN PARTICULAR I
THINK WE HAVE ACTUALLY
KNOWLEDGE IN THE PROPOSED
DECISION THESE OTHER BENEFITS
AS YOU MENTIONED AND THE
TREMENDOUS- IN A FIT OF HAVING
THAT TAXIS AS EXAMPLE.
SERPENTOR THERE IS OPPORTUNITY
THERE AND WE HOPE TO HEAR FROM
ANY FURTHER REFINEMENTS AND SO
WE WELCOME THAT. TIME THESE
COMMENTS I'VE NOW AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO- MY SOON AS ARE ALL
PARTY IS SCHEDULED ALSO BE
HAPPY TO SHARE THOSE DATES AND
TIMES ADAM YOUR OFFICE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS WE'VE GOT A
COUPLE MEMBERS THIS YEAR WHEN
ASKED TO SEE IF- THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF. ANY OF THESE
PRESENTERS. REMEMBER CREATES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANNA FOLLOW UP ON YOUR
QUESTION REGARDING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT SO A LOT
CAN BE SAID ABOUT WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE WHY WHY WE
NEED TO LOOKING AT. THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS HEADED AS
MASSIVE. AS SOME OF THE STEM
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
IF THE IF YOU CAN ELABORATE
JUST A LITTLE IN TERMS OF- SOME
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
ENVIRONMENTALIST- ENVIRONMENTAL
RIGHTS GROUPS. IN TERMS OF THE
PROS AND CONS OR HOW WE GET TO
A- A GOOD PLACE WITH REGARDS TO
EXTRACTION DEVELOPMENT. AND
REALLY CALIFORNIA PLANA A ROLE
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT AS WE HAVE. A
CERTAIN GOALS THAT WE NEED TO
ACHIEVE 1100% RENEWABLE BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THAT WE ARE
ALSO. THINKING ABOUT WAYS IN
WHICH WE ARE PROACTIVELY. ALSO
PROTECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT AT
THE SAME TIME AND CURIOUS IF
YOU CAN ELABORATE ON THAT JUST
A BIT AND I AND I UNDERSTAND
MISTER TURNER WILL ALSO. BE
HAVE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK SIMILAR QUESTIONS TO
ADDITIONAL PANELISTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- YEAH I JUST WOULD I
GUESS BEGIN BY TWENTY I THINK
FOSSIL FUEL EXTRACTION HAS
BEEN. ONE OF THE MOST HARMFUL
THINGS TO COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE WORLD AND PERSONALLY
EVERYWHERE ONLINE AFRICA OUT OF
THIS IS THAT JUST THE LOCAL
POLLUTION AND EMISSIONS- AND-
DOES INDUSTRIES OFTEN HAVE-
FULLER JOBS THAT THE ARE ALSO
LEARNING PRACTICAL HEALTH AND I
THINK. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SIX ABOUT THIS RESOURCE IS THAT
IT IS BY FAR THE GREENEST AND
MOST SUSTAINABLE WAY TO RECOVER
LITHIUM. ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
SO IN ARGENTINA AND CHILE THE
WAY THEY GET A LOOK HERE MISS
THESE MASSIVE EVAPORATION
PONDS- WERE THERE TO TAKE A
QUITE A BIG FOOTPRINT TO DO
THAT IN PLACES LIKE CHINA AND
AUSTRALIA GOOD MORNING WILL
ROCK. UP IN A DUSTING IT UP BUT
IT'S- IT HAS A BIGGER FOOTPRINT
THIS IS BASICALLY TAKING THE
SUPERHEATED GROWING THAT'S
ALREADY BELOW THE GROUND IS
ALREADY BEING CYCLE DIGITAL
POWER PLANTS. YEAH THERE'S A
PROCESS TO WITHDRAW THE
LITHIUM- THERE'S MULTIPLE
TECHNOLOGIES TO DO THIS ONE OF
THEM IS THEY JUST HAVE THIS
ALSO BASICALLY TRACTABILITY OF
THE TECHNOLOGY WHICH WOULD
THINK ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES
COUPLE DIFFERENT BILL OF THAT
BUT IT'S A VERY VERY LIGHT.
FOOTPRINT CLOSED LOOP ZERO
WASTE PROCESS- AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY ONE OF THE EXCITING
THINGS THAT WE CAN PRODUCES AT
SCALE BUT HOW ABOUT- REALLY
REALLY MINIMAL IMPACT AND I
THINK THAT'S- GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND. AND GOOD FOR
LARGER GOALS AS WELL. THANK I
THINK THERE'S FOLLOW UP. THING
YOU MISTER- CHAIR CHILD AYE AYE
HAVE I HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN TO
THE LITHIUM. MINES AND SHE AND
TOTAL AND HAVE C. FIRST HAND.
OUT WHAT THOSE PLANS LOOK LIKE
AND HOW THE LITHIUM IS
EXTRACTED THROUGH PIPELINES AND
SO. OF COURSE THAT IT LOOKS A
CERTAIN WAY IT HAS A CERTAIN
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT A- CHILLER
SELLS MOST OF ITS- MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM THAT TRIP IS
THAT SHE'LL ALSO SELLS MOST OF
ITS- LITHIUM TO CHINA SO AGAIN
THERE'S THE COMPETITIVE NATURE
OF. OF WHAT THAT MARKET LOOKS
LIKE AND WHAT THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA LOOK LIKE AND I
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED IN AND
KNOWING A LITTLE BIT MORE. OF
THE SOME OF THE EXTRACTION
METHODS- THAT. CAN LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT AND ARE MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND AND
FAMILY THAT WOULD THAT WHAT I
SAW IN CHILE SO THINK THANK YOU
FOR THAT. WHAT IS THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE LIKE TO
EXPLORE WITH THE LIFFEY VALLEY
COMMISSION IS. ACTUALLY A SITE
VISIT- FOR INTERESTED MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO GO
TOGETHER AND BRING. SOME OF OUR
EXPERTS SPOTTED A BUNCH OF
THESE- DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS.
DONE I THINK I LOOK HEREFROM.
A COUPLE THE DEVELOPERS WHO ARE
WORKING ON THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
THE ACTORS WHO CAN SPEAK TO
THAT BUT THAT'S SOMETHING WE
LOOK TO. TO GO DOWN TOGETHER-
FOR ANY. MEMBERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED TO SEE. A DOCTOR SAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I WOULD
WORK SO TO EXTEND THAT IN. TO
MY CAR. UP IT. GETS A HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE DEGREES OUT THERE
SO. I WILL TRY TO PULL THAT
OFF- EITHER SPEAK FOR OR AFTER-
THAT TIME. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THREE OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY- AND- SETTING THE TONE
FOR THIS CONVERSATION- THE NEXT
THAT PERSON WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT. LITHIUM VALLEY THE
ACTUAL REGION BY THE CEO OF
IMPERIAL COUNTY. WE WILL HAVE
BEEN. ANOTHER GROUP OF
PANELISTS WHO WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMMUNICATION MIX- THAT MIGHT
BE ABLE TO ANSWER A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS. THAT HAVE COME UP
WITH THIS SPECIFIC. DISCUSSION
SLEPT ENOUGH. AFTER THE CEO AND
I'VE KIND OF GONE. ALL RIGHT ON
THE AGENDA WE DO HAVE ACTUAL-
DEVELOPERS WHO WILL TALK ABOUT
THE SPECIFICS OF THE TECHNOLOGY
AND PEOPLE WILL GET THE ASSAM
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. ABOUT THAT
SO WHAT THANK YOU AGAIN AND
THAT WILL MOVE ON. WITH THE
AGENDA WILL NOW INTRODUCE THE
THIRD PART CALIFORNIA'S THIS
YEAR VALLEY TWENTY WERE
HOLDERS. JUNIOR IS A CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF IMPERIAL
COUNTY HOME GROWN. AND SAYS
SOMEONE WHO'S WILL KIND OF GIVE
US AN OVERVIEW OF THE REGION.
AND THEY CAN BE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THIS PRESENTS. WHICH CO
WELCOME- THIS ELEMENT SEE IT
YOU FOR THIS OP. TO SPEAK-
FIRST OF ALL- BEFORE WE GET
STARTED ON THE LITHIUM I THINK
THE STREAMLINED BURDEN TO
RECOGNIZE A PARTNERSHIP THAT-
AND THE GREAT WORK THAT
ASSEMBLY MAIN. MEMBER GARCIA
HAS DONE THROUGH THE COLAVITA
ACTIVITY HERE TO GROW COUNTY IS
ONE OF THE- HARDEST REGIONS-
STRICKEN BY A CODED UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA HAS JUST
DONE AN AWESOME JOB AND BEEN A
GREAT PARTNER. AND- IT SEEN AS-
ANY ASSETS OR ANY RESOURCES WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY. AND I
THINK THE REASON I WANT TO
BRING THAT UP IS BECAUSE- IT
SHOWS THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
DO HAVE AND WHAT WE WILL MAKE
HAPPEN- AND THEN TURNED THINGS
AROUND WITH THE SUPPORT. OF
OTHERS- A ARE YOU ALSO MAY.
LOOK LOCATION LOCATION SO LET'S
JUST SAY IMPERIAL COUNTY IS
THAT LOCATION LOCATION LOCATION
SO LET'S MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
AGAIN MY NAME'S TONY ROAD IS
PROUD TO BE THE CEO OF
ACCOUNTABLE CARE. I'VE HELD
THIS POSITION FOR- GOING ON FOR
YEARS AND- PROBABLY THE COUNTY
OF PREVIOUSLY- IN MY LIFETIME I
WORK I WORK FOR THE COUNTY
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO
ACTUALLY- IN THE- IN THE FIRE
SERVICE SO- PROBABLY SERVE MY
COMMUNITY. AND THE REASON- I'M
PROUD OF IT IS BECAUSE I'M
PROUD OF AND PRO COUNTY I'M
PROUD OF THE OVERALL COMMUNITY
AND WHAT WE BRING FORTH AND-
IT'S JUST A GREAT PLACE TO LIVE
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES- I CALL THEM PEARL
COUNTY MY ENTIRE HOME. AND IT
WITNESSED A COMMUNITY STRENGTH
AND UNIFIED DESPITE MANY
LONGSTANDING ISSUES. AND
CHALLENGES SCOLDING SUMMERS AND
I HEARD A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
DEGREES AND I'LL LET YOU GUYS
KNOW IT'S NOT A HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE DEGREES BUT IT WILL BE A
HUNDRED NAY BY NEXT WEEK SO
ANYBODY DOING VISIT YOU WANT TO
HURRY UP AND- MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
MOST RECENTLY- DEVASTATED BY
THE IMPACTS OF CODED NINETEEN
WE ARE COMMUNITY- THAT HAS FOR
DECADES BEEN FACED WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS COMPARABLE
TO AN ECONOMIC DEPRESSION AND
BATTLE DECADES LONG ENVIRONMENT
ISSUES ON BOTH SIDES OF OUR
LARGE COUNTY WELL KNOWN PRO
COUNTY AS A LARGE COUNTY-
SPARSELY SPREAD OUT OF
PROVIDING SERVICES BUT
PROVIDING A QUALITY OF LIFE
OVER A LARGE COUNTY CAN BE.
QUITE DIFFICULT- FROM OUR
SOUTHERN AND WE WELCOME OF SOME
OF THE MOST POLLUTED RIVERS IN
NORTH AMERICA AND TO OUR
NORTHERN END WITH THE SEA
EVAPORATING AND LEAVING FIND US
THAT WILL FIND ITS WAYS IN THE
LUNGS OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES-
HABITING AREA AROUND. ALTHOUGH
THESE ARE JUST A COUPLE OF THE
MANY ISSUES THAT SPAN DECADES
AND NOW MY ENTIRE LIFE AND
PRIOR TO THAT. I THINK IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THERE ARE
MANY INTO COUNTY WHO FILLED
THAT ROLE- WE HAVE BEEN UNSEEN
UNHEARD. AND QUITE FRANKLY
FORGOTTEN- BY INDIVIDUALS AT
CERTAIN TIMES. BUT THESE ARE
THE SAME INDIVIDUALS THAT MAKE
DECISIONS. THAT CAN BE
RESPONSIBLE TO CREATE
POSITIVITY THAT WILL BE
IMPACTING OUR QUALITY OF LIFE
HERE IN THE REAL NEAR FUTURE.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY WE THIS IS
TRUE OR NOT TRUE- I THINK WE
WITH THIS- HEARING TODAY SHOWS
THAT WERE ON THE PROPER
DIRECTION OF THE POSITIVITY OF
THINGS TO COME. BUT WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE BORN INTO A
COMMUNITY WITH THESE ISSUES IT
FILLS UP THERE'S LITTLE
PROGRESS IS BEING DONE AS YEARS
AND YEARS GO BY. IT'S EASY TO
IMAGINE WHY ONE WOULD FEEL THIS
WAY. AND WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
FOR ME AS A COUNTY CEO LET THE
M. ISN'T JUST A CHANCE TO
EXPAND OUR RESERVES OR CREATE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES. WITHIN MY
DEPARTMENT. WE'RE WILLING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. AND WE'RE NOT
WILLING JUST TO CREATE JOBS
WILL AND ALSO HELP ASSIST
PEOPLE LEARN AND- BE THOSE JOB-
APPLICANTS- GIVE THEM THE- KNOW
HOW GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES
DISK SUCCEED IN THOSE JOBS AND
WE'LL DO THAT WITH OUR
WORKFORCE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. WE'LL DO THAT WITH
OUR LOCAL AND CURL BELLY
COLLEGE WE HAVE DOCTOR MARTHA
GARCIA ON ON THE PANEL TODAY
AND SHE'S JUST ONE OF THE
ASSETS HERE AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
THAT WILL DEFINITELY BE AT THE
TABLE TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN. IT'S
A PROSPECT OF AN IMPROVED
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR EMPLOYEES
FAMILY FRIENDS NEIGHBORS AND
ALL THOSE WHO CONTROL COUNTY
HOME. COUPLED WITH THE
ABUNDANCE OF RESOURCES AT THE
SALTON SEA KNOWN GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCE AREA IS ALL MOTIVATES
OUR BOARD AND MYSELF. TO PURSUE
DEVELOPMENT OF INDUSTRY IN OUR
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
OUR RESIDENTS PROPRI PROVIDING
JOBS TRAINING EDUCATION THAT
COMES WITH INVESTING AND HUMAN
RESOURCES AND SUPPORTING OUR
COMMUNITY BY BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER FOR COLLECTIVE EFFORT
AND ALLOWING THEM TO BE A PART
OF SOMETHING WHETHER THAT'S TO
BE A PART OF THE COMPANY THE
ORGANIZATION ADMINISTRATION.
WE'RE JUST HOPING TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE SPENT THEIR LIVES JUST
HOPING TO NOT BEING SUCCESSFUL
BUT HAVING A CHANCE FOR THAT
SUCCESS AND BEING PART OF THE
OVERALL PLAN BEING DEVELOPED TO
DISCUSS TODAY. OPPORTUNITIES
ARE FAR INVOLVED FAR FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN HERE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY. BUT I'VE LIVED HERE AND
WORKED HERE LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT WHEN ONE DOES APPEAR. WE
WILL TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE. AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE CREATE
OPPORTUNITY. THIS IS WHY WE
HAVE INVESTED SO MUCH TIME
EFFORT AND RESOURCES INTO
BECOMING THE HUB FOR RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO ATTRACT INVESTORS
WHICH INCLUDE ELECTRIC CAR
BATTERY MANUFACTURERS AND THOSE
WHO CAN MAXIMIZE OUR VAST
NATURAL RESOURCES. AND
AVAILABLE AND READY WORKFORCE.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN RENEWABLE
ENERGY INDUSTRY WITH NUMEROUS
SOLAR WIND AND GEOTHERMAL
PROJECTS IN THE COUNTY. WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO PLAY A
MUCH BIGGER ROLE. IN THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY FUTURE OF OUR
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
A LITHIUM AND OTHER MINERALS
MINERAL RECOVERY. EFFORTS.
BENEFITS CAN EXTEND A G.
COMMUNITY ALSO NOT JUST THOSE
DIRECTLY GAINING FROM A NEW JOB
LIKE CONTROL COUNTY PUBLIC
BENEFIT PROGRAM WHICH MAXIMIZES
THE BENEFITS OF SOLAR
DEVELOPMENT ENERGY AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY. WE'VE SEEN THIS- LOVES
OUR LOCAL EFFORTS AS WHAT WE'VE
DONE WITH OUR- COMMUNITY
BENEFIT MONIES THAT WERE-
GATHERED THROUGH OUR SOLAR
DEVELOPMENT HERE IN A PRO
COUNTY. AND WE'VE INJECTED- AND
REINVESTED OVER THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS BACK IN OUR
COMMUNITY OUR OUR COMMUNITY BY
SUPPORTING VARIOUS PROJECTS
SUCH AS INFRASTRUCTURE.
MANUFACTURING PARKS AND OTHER
GREAT ENDEAVORS. JUST RECENTLY
WE USE SOME OF THAT MONEY TO
REINVEST IN THEIR BUSINESSES-
RESTAURANTS AND TO OUR LOCAL
CITIZENS BY ASSISTING WITH
COSTS THAT WERE INCURRED DURING
TO THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THAT'S HOW MUCH WE BELIEVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND WE KNOW WE
NEED TO REINVEST. TODAY I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA GET NUMBERS DATA
AND INFORMATION REGARDING STUDY
AFTER STUDY THROWN AT YOU. BUT
I HOPE THROUGHOUT TODAY'S
HEARING YOU DON'T FRGET THAT
ALL THE STATISTICS DON'T
TRANSLATE TO WHAT'S INVESTING
AND TO LET THEM AND OUR REGION.
AND WHAT IT CAN DO FOR THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTY OUR STATE
AND OUR BI NATIONAL REGION. A
REGION THAT THOUGH IS RESILIENT
IS STILL IN RECOVERY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
PEOPLE AT HEART. AND I HOPE
TODAY CAN SPUR ACTION THAT IS
MUCH NEEDED. AND HAS BEEN LONG
OVERDUE ALONG COMING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF ONTARIO COUNTY. AND
AGAIN AS NOT JUST A- COMMUNITY
LEADER OF THIS COUNTY. BUT AS A
RESIDENT SOMEONE THAT'S RAISE
THEIR FAMILY IN THIS COMMUNITY.
I AM HERE AS A PARTNER TO DO
WHATEVER I CAN IN MY EFFORT
SUPPORT MY BOARD. AND GIVE THEM
THE PROPER DIRECTION TO SEE
THIS COME TO FRUITION ERIN
APPROACH CANDY AND SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I MISS. A
ROTISSERIE QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY FOR- SEAL HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE MIGHT GET BACK TO
YOU- AFTER THESE NEXT SET A
PRESENTER THANK YOU. AGAIN FOR
MR WITH US. THE NEXT UP PORTION
OF THE AGENDA HAS A LITTLE
RECOVERY AND TECHNOLOGIES WE
HAVE THREE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK OUT AND
IF YOU'LL VALLEY REGION WE
HAVE- JOHNATHAN WEISS GIRL WITH
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH BERKSHIRE
HATHAWAY. ENERGY BROUGHT
CALDWELL CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER CONTROLLED THERMAL
RESOURCES AND DEREK BENSON
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER OF
ENERGY SOURCE ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE HERE WITH US
TELECONFERENCING TODAY WE'LL
START WITH THAT MISTER JONATHAN
WIDESCALE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MORE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
HEAR ME. GOOD WE OCT. I I DON'T
HAVE A PREPARED STATEMENT WHAT
I WANT TO DO THOSE KIND OF PLAY
CLEAN UP HERE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
ALREADY COME UP BUT LET ME TALK
ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY FOR
LITHIUM PRODUCTION. THAT'S BEEN
ASKED ABOUT HIM SOME TIME LINES
AND SOME OF THE BARRIERS AND
HURDLES- WE STARTED THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO AS CAL ENERGY WE OWN
AND OPERATE TEN OF THE ELEVEN
GEOTHERMAL PLANTS. ADJACENT OF
THE SALT SEA WHERE WE PRODUCE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MEGAWATTS
OF GEOTHERMAL POWER WE'VE GOT
TWENTY ONE GEO THERMAL
PRODUCTION WELLS AND THEY PUT
THEY BRING UP GEOTHERMAL BRINE
AT TEMPERATURES AS HIGH AS
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT. AND THAT BRIAN IT'S
A SATURATED SOLUTION OF MANY
DISSOLVED MINERALS IT'S GOT
IRON CALCIUM YOU KNOW SODIUM
POTASSIUM MANGANESE MET.
MAGNESIUM ZINC AND OF COURSE
WITH HIM AND WE'VE BEEN
PROCESSING FIFTY THOUSAND
GALLONS A MINUTE OF THIS BRIAN
FOR THE PAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
TO PRODUCE THAT GEOTHERMAL
POWER. NOW THAT BRIAN'S GOT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PARTS PER MILLION
OF LITHIUM- THAT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE A LOT BUT IF WE CAN
RECOVER. THAT LITHIUM BY THE
WAY I DON'T TALK ABOUT
EXTRACTING IT I'M TALKING ABOUT
RECOVERY AND WE'RE NOT MINING.
A THOUSAND TIMES A YEAR IN A
WORLD MARKET TODAY OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND SO WE
COULD EASILY SUPPLY AT LEAST A
QUARTER OF CURRENT WORLD DEMAND
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS NOT BEEN
PROVEN ON A COMMERCIAL SCALE
AND THAT'S BEEN THE BARRIER SO
WHERE GOAL IS WE WANT TO CRAWL
BEFORE WE WALK AND WALK BEFORE
WE RUN SO WHERE GOAL WAS LET'S
GET THERE ARE IN THE FUNDING TO
BUILD DEMONSTRATION PLANTS. AT
A ONE TENTH COMMERCIAL SCALE TO
DO THIS WE CAN RECOVER LITHIUM
IN THE LAB IT'S NOT ALCHEMY
IT'S THERE WHAT HOW DO YOU
PROVE IT UP AND SCALE. WE
APPLIED FOR TWO SEPARATE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS ONE FROM THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND ONE FROM
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
WE WANT BOTH OF THEM. A SIX
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FROM THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. TO SHOW THAT
WE CAN PRODUCE THE WITH HIM AND
A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY.
TO CONVERT THAT LITHIUM
CHLORIDE INTO THE FEEDSTOCK FOR
A BATTERY WHICH IS LITHIUM
HYDROXIDE- WE WANT BOTH AND WE
ARE MATCHING THOSE TWO GRANTS
ONE OF SIX MILLION ONE OF
FIFTEEN. WITH AN ADDITIONAL SIX
MILLION AND FIFTEEN OF THEIR
OWN FUNDS SO WHERE FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
PROCESS. NOW LET ME GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS REALLY QUICKLY
FIRST THE BRIAN IS PROCESS FOR
GEOTHERMAL DEVELOPMENT IT COMES
OUT WE FLASH IT AT FIVE HUNDRED
DEGREES. MEDIALLY COMES DOWN TO
ABOUT TWO FIFTY. HOW DO YOU GET
THE LITHIUM HAVE YOU SEPARATED
FROM THE BRINE. WE GOT WHAT'S
CALLED A I. ONYX. TECH THINK OF
IT KIND OF IS AMONG AMONG.
SIEVE THAT. LIKE EXTRA THE
LISTING. BUT REJECT REJECT THE
OTHER METALS THE IMPURITIES THE
ONES LIKE TICKED OFF THE
MAGNESIUM THE IRON CALCIUM
DISODIUM. SO THIS TECHNOLOGY
CAN HANDLE THE HIGH
TEMPERATURES IT CAN PRECIPITATE
OUT THE LITHIUM- LEAVING THE
IRON MAGNESIUM IN THE BRYANT
AND REJECT THOSE OTHER METALS.
THAT CAN GO BACK DOWN HOLE INTO
THE GEOTHERMAL RESERVOIR
WITHOUT PRECIPITATING THEM OUT.
SO AT THE END OF THAT PROCESS
WE'VE GOT LITHIUM CHLORIDE. AND
THEN WE GO TO STEP TWO
CONVERTING THAT TO LITHIUM
HYDROXIDE. FOR WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO USE ELECTROLYSIS
SIMPLY USING AN ELECTRIC
CURRENT- TO CHURCH DRIVE A
CHEMICAL CHANGE TO GO FROM.
CHLORIDE TO HYDROXIDE- AND BY
THE WAY THE ELECTRICITY WILL
USE WILL BE RENEWABLE ENERGY IT
WILL BE A GEO THERMAL POWER-
AND THEN WE WILL GO THROUGH
MORE. PURIFICATION
CRYSTALLIZATION AND THE LIKE TO
TURN WILL THIS LIQUID INTO A
POWER. POWER TIME LONG. YOU
KNOW I WE WANT UNDER AND TO BUT
ME TELL YOU THE KERR TIME THE
DEMONSTRATION PLANNED FOR K.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION- WE WANT THAT THAT'S
WE'RE GOING TO BREAK GROUND
NEXT MONTH- IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS WE HOPE THAT WILL BE
ONLINE BY JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WITH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY CONVERSION
PLANT AGAIN BOTH DEMONSTRATION
PLANTS ONLINE BY LATE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IF THOSE ARE
SUCCESSFUL- WILL THEN BEGIN.
COLLECTING DATA PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY GRANT ALSO
COVERS. THE DEVELOPMENT OF FULL
SCALE COMMERCIAL ENGINEERING
AND THE LIKE SO WE COULD BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION AS AS EARLY AS
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR BUT WE'VE
GOT TO DO THE ENGINEERING AND
PERMITTING- AND GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW THIS WORKS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT JOB CREATION
LATER BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT WILL
ALSO BE ARE QUITE SIGNIFICANT.
SO- WE- WE THINK THAT
SUCCESSFUL LITHIUM PRODUCTION
CAN ALSO BE A CATALYST. TO
pINDUSTRY SO WE'RE NOT JUST
CREATING JOBS AND WITH THEM.
BUT ALSO REDUCING THE PRICE OF
GEOTHERMAL POWER IN A WAY WITH
THEM CAN BE THE TAIL THAT WAGS
THE GEOTHERMAL DAHLE. TO BE
QUITE FRANK. GEOTHERMAL POWER
CAN'T COME RIGHT NOW FOR COST
WITH WIND AND SOLAR IT'S GOT TO
RIFIC ATTRIBUTES ITS BASELOAD
AS YOU HEARD IT CAN EASILY
REPLACE DIABLO CANYON WHICH
WIND AND SOLAR FARM CAN'T DO.
BUT IT'S SIMPLY MORE EXPENSIVE
IF YOU CAN GET THAT SECONDARY
STREAM OF INCOME GOING FROM
LITHIUM YOU CAN REDUCE THE COST
OF THAT GEOTHERMAL POWER SO. WE
SEE A LOT OF SYNERGIES HERE
JUST WITH LOCAL BENEFITS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY EVEN
GROW THE GEO THERMAL- INDUSTRY
IN IMPERIAL VALLEY WHICH IN
TURN CAN GREW THE LITHIUM
INDUSTRY. NOW BARRIERS RISKS
LET ME GO THROUGH THOSE
QUICKLY. WE'VE REALLY GOT TO DE
RISK THREE THINGS WE GOT TO THE
REST OF THE TECHNOLOGY WE'VE
GOT TO DE RISK THE PRODUCTION
OF THE LITHIUM AND WE WANT TO
DE RISK THE MARKET. SO DE
RISKING THE TECHNOLOGY PRETTY
MUCH COVER THAT WE NEED TO SEE
ISN'T TECHNICALLY COMMERCIALLY
FEASIBLE TO RELIABLY EXTRACT
REAL LIFTING HIM FROM THIS
BRIAN IN AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE WAY. SO THAT'S
THREE PARTS RIGHT THERE THE
TECHNICAL THE COMMERCIAL AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND WITH THE
SENATE ANY ENERGY COMMISSION
GRANT WE'VE GOT TO DO THAT FOR
UNDER THREE FOUR THOUSAND.
DOLLARS A TON. WE'VE GOT PROOF
PROOF OF CONCEPT WE'RE ON OUR%
WAY SO LET'S GO TO DE RISKING
THE PRODUCTION. ARE THE LAST
GEOTHERMAL PLANT WE PERMITTED
TOOK FOUR YEARS TO DESIGN AND
PERMIT- WE CAN'T TAKE THAT LONG
I MEAN A KEY OBSTACLE HERE WILL
BE NEEDED GOVERNMENT APPROVAL
WHICH- WE HOPE WE CAN EXPEDITE
THAT PROCESS. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
AND EARLY ENGAGEMENT WILL
REDUCE POTENTIAL OPPOSITION
POTENTIAL DELAYS AS WELL AS
STATE AN INTERAGENCY
COOPERATION AND STREAMLINING
WOULD CLEARLY SPEED UP THAT
PROCESS. I DO WANT TO SAY ON
COMMUNITY OUTREACH WE HAVE
ALREADY HELD ONE VIRTUAL TOWN
HALL MEETING BACK IN MARCH WE
HAD OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ATTENDEES WE HAD OTHER
MEETINGS. I ACTUALLY UNDER YOUR
AUSPICES. MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH
SOME OTHER IN FIREMEN JUSTICE
GROUP. AND WE INTO TO HOLD A-
PUBLIC- TOWN MEETING JULY. AND
WOULD HOPE. INVITE AS MANY AS
WE TO COME. OTHER DE RISKING
THEIR WORK THAT GREAT WORKFORCE.
WE'RE ALREADY WORKING WITH
IMPERIAL COUNTY COLLEGE ON
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT WE NEED
TO WORK ON INCENTIVES
OPPORTUNITY ZONES ENTERPRISE
ZONES LOTS OF DIFFERENT CREDITS
BOTH AT THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL. AND LASTLY WE'VE GOT TO
WORK- ON ANCILLARY ISSUES- ROAD
IMPROVEMENTS THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW ARE THAT THAT WILL THAT
WILL MAKE THIS WORK BROADBAND
IMPROVEMENT- DOWN IN THAT AREA
THAT WILL HELP ATTRACT THE WORK
FORCE. AND THEN THAT THIRD DE
RISKING YES WE GOTTA DO RISK
THE MARKET- THESE ARE LONG TERM
CONTRACTS WE NEED TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT CALIFORNIA IS ON THE MAP
FOR LITHIUM PRODUCTION- THIS
THIS COMMITTEE IS GREAT- TO DO
THAT THE LITHIUM VALLEY
COMMISSION I THINK IS DOING
THAT. I WOULD LOVE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TO LEAD A REVERSE TRADE
MISSION BRING IN OFF TAKERS TO
SHOW WHAT WE CAN DO AND MIND
YOU WE'RE COMPETING HERE I MEAN
THERE IS A THERE'S A RACE
RIGHT. FOR LITHIUM AND IT'S NOT
JUST AROUND THE WORLD WITH AS
YOU HEARD FROM CHAIRMAN HOPE
SHE'LL IT'S NOT JUST SOUTH
AMERICA AUSTRALIA AND CHINA
IT'S NOW GERMANY IT'S NOW THE
UNITED KINGDOM AND IN THE
UNITED STATES AS YOU HEARD
ALREADY NEVADA. ARKANSAS NORTH
CAROLINA SO THERE'S A LOT TO DO
HERE LET ME JUST SUM UP AND
THEN DELIGHTED TO TAKE
QUESTIONS BUT- ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WAS ASKED WHY
YOU KNOW WHY LITHIUM VALLEY.
WHAT THE- FOR AND FOREMOST IT'S
THE OBVIOUS ONE THE- IS. OF
WE'RE OR NAY. THE O. FOR POWER
WE'RE LOOKING AT A- ON CHECK.
JUST PRECIPITATE OUT WITH THE
IS AS CHAIRMAN OF DISK.
SECONDLY WE TERM SUPPLY THERE'S
A LEAST A SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
SUPPLY PROP. LONG AND IT'S PROP
THE LARGEST. LITHIUM RESERVOIR
IN THE WORLD. SCIENTISTS ARE
WORKING ON THAT AS WELL. NUMBER
THREE THERE THERE IS A WATER
NEED AND BE DELIGHTED TO
ADDRESS THAT- IN ID IS AWARE OF
THAT THERE THERE WILL BE A
WATER NEED ON THE PURIFICATION.
OF THAT. ION EXCHANGE
TECHNOLOGY- THERE'S A GROWING
SHIFT TO ELECTRIC VEHICLE
PRODUCTION SO IN NORTH AMERICAN
A RELIABLE NORTH AMERICAN
SUPPLY. OF A CRITICAL ELEMENT
LIKE LITHIUM- IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT IN
FACT. I WOULD ARGUE THERE'S
EVEN A NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERN HERE ABOUT THE NEED TO
PRODUCE LITHIUM WHICH AS YOU
SAID MISTER CHAIR. WE'VE ONLY
PRODUCED WOULD PRODUCE A TINY
BIT. NUMBER FIVE THE LOGISTICAL
ADVANTAGE YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
THAT FOR SOUTHERNCALIFORNIA.
AND LASTLY THIS WILL BE THE
MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE LITHIUM PRODUCTION
IN THE WORLD ALREADY WE RETURN
ERROR UNUSED BRIAN IT'S
RECYCLED ITS RETURN TO THE
RESERVOIR. WE WILL BE TAKING
OUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PARTS PER
MILLION OF LITHIUM- IT'S A
PHYSICALLY. TINY FOOTPRINT
COMPARED TO SOUTH AMERICA WHAT
YOU SEEN UP CARILLO AND WHAT WE
SEE IN IN AUSTRALIA AND CHINA.
DOESN'T USE THESE EVAPORATION
PONDS AND THIS CLOSED LOOP
RECOVERY WE THINK WE'LL AVOID
THE SCARRED LANDSCAPE- THE
TOXIC WATER CONTAMINATION. THE
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION
THAT WE SEE AROUND THE WORLD
AND AS I SAID LASTLY WE'LL BE
USING RENEWABLE ENERGY
GEOTHERMAL POWER FOR THE
ELECTRICITY NEEDS WE HAVE. LET
ME STOP THERE A BE DELIGHTED TO
ASK ANY QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT
COME UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT THANK YOU GOT THE WORLD
OFTEN QUESTION ON. I SHOULD
UNTIL THE LAST. AT JUMP FRIDAY
ROCKAUTO. CHIEF OF COULD DOUBLE
RESOURCES PLEASE. PRESS AT
THANK THANK YOU CHAN AND MEMBER
IT SAID PRIVY TO PRESENT YOU-
PAMELA THE PUBLIC TODAY I
ACTUALLY HAVE A- PRESS. HE OF
WE CAN. YEAH WELL TO SHARE THAT.
IS WITH. OKAY I BEGIN ALL SAY
THAT I'M- I GUESS YEAH I LISTEN
TO THE GENERAL- CONSENSUS OF
THE MEMBERS AND YOU CHAIRMAN
AND THE PUBLIC OUT PROBABLY
LIKE TO REALLY HIGH IN ON ON-
MORE THE ENVIRONMENTAL- SOME OF
THE- ENVIRONMENTAL- BENEFITS I
GUESS AND SO TO TRIED TO DISPEL
SOME OF THE- THE ISSUES ABOUT-
HAVE THIS IS ACTUALLY PRODUCE
AND I THINK SOME OF THE-
QUESTIONS BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
BOUGHT OUT SO ABOUT TO JUST
PROBABLY HìNH IN ON THAT THE
PRESS. OF THE QUARTER BRUHL.
SPECTRUMS I FIRST A LITTLE
ABOUT THE HELL'S KITCHEN NOT
WITH HIM COOPER WE ARE JOINED-
BUT YOU HAVE TO AND ENERGIES.
PROJECTS WE ACT WHAT THE BRING
FILLED- DEVELOPER THAT'S- A TO
THE SHORT OF LA ARE STILL ON
THE- SUDDEN SEA THAT IS- SO WAY
SORT STARTING SCRATCH AND I
GUESS YOU KNOW WE- ARE LOOKING
AT. MY WITH THE ALL HATE THE
FACT MY SENSE IN A BAR FOR
WEISS. STAGE ONE OF PRIDE IS A
FORTY NINE POINT NINE MEGAWATT
SINGLE PAL PLAN THE TWENTY
PRODUCE TWENTY TO METRIC TONS
YEAR. THAT COULD HYDROXIDE
THAT'LL COME LAW TWENTY TWO
THREE THE TWENTY FOUR- TOTAL
REYES COULD- THIS IS A LARGE
RESOURCE JONATHAN HIT ON. WE
COULD ALL ONLY BE JUST L. A. C.
UP TO THREE. THOUSAND TIME BE A
L. C. AND- HUNDRED. OF POWER
COULD IF. REPLACE THE EMPLOYEE
CANYON- SO VERY LARGE SCUTTLED
RESULTS. AND THAT'S UP LEAST-
TO ABLE TO READ. STYLE UP AND
SORT OF- WILL GO A QUICK AS-
COMES ON BOTH- I'M GOING TO
THIS TEAM BUT YOU OF SAY WHERE
THE THEMES- SO YEAH OF. TO HOST
CHILDHOOD ON THE- AMONG OTHER
WHERE I THINK WE GOING TO HAVE
A- POINT OF. YEAH WE'RE IN
HOLIDAY SUPPLY K. HE- THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO SAY IN
THE ON THE SLIDE BUT- IT REALLY
DEFICIT STUFF TO COME IN TWENTY
TWO TWO TO TWENTY THREE ON A
OUT OF HERE SO I'M JUST. FOR
THE ADDED I TO DIE GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF GIVE. GIGAWATT HOURS
AND- MEGA FACTORIES AND TEAR
FACTORY. OR IN SOME OTHER AREAS
THAT YOU COULD SAY HE- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE VERY LARGE OPEN TOP-
WHOLE BODIES. YEAH THIS ROCK
HAS TO BE YOU KNOW IT'S BUT
IT'S GENERALLY ABOUT 6% IN
LITHIUM CONCENTRATION SO EVERY
HUNDRED TONS OF ALL YOU MIGHT
GET SIX TONS OF WITH HIM OUT OF
THAT IN THE FORMS BUDGET MAIN.
YEAH THIS OR IS A TRUCK IN
TRYING TO THEN SHIPPED TO CHINA
WELL SOUTH KOREA FOR POSTCRISIS
APPROVED VERY VERY CRUDE
PRICES. THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF
ALL OF THAT AND I'LL BE NEEDS
TO COME BACK STATES
TO- BATTERY MANUFACTURES THE
SOUTH KOREA'S. VERY EXPENSIVE-
THERE INTENSE PRICE SIMILAR-
THINK OF THE MEN. THE CHASE
TOUCH ON THIS UNITED IS I THINK.
THE CALL. WHICH IS ON THE ON
RIGHT HAND SIDE YOU SEE NOW TEN
THE IALL THE VEPR. PA WHEN YOU.
THE SIZE IN A CALM. HAS A LIST
THAN ONE INCH OF RAIN A YEAR.
AND THEY PONZI USING A ME HALF
A MINUTE GALLONS OF OIL- PROVED
AFTER. OR EVERYONE TIME BLITZ
IN. COULD YOU SUCK IT I'S
PROBABLY THE AND SUSTAINABLE-
CATEGORY- THIS IS A IT'S BEING
DONE FOCUS MANY. THAT IT'S VERY
EFFECTIVE. COSTA TOM YOU KNOW
OF AB. TO 12-1 A MONTH- A THEN
A GUY IN THAT. SO WITH. IS
GENERALLY CENTER- TO. ASIA FULL
PLAY. PROCESSING. I'M SIMILARLY
TO CO TWO SO YEAH THAT'S THE
WAY USE IS MORE THESE LARGER ON-
THE SEATTLE SET EVERY I GUESS
THE- THE ON THE ON THE LEFT
HAND SIDE. FOR EVERY ONE TIME
PUBLIC HIM PROJECT THIS FORTY
POINT NIGHT. OF TWO PRODUCED
THAT'S A SPOT MAKES THE HARD.
TO I READ THE I SHOWED- SIMPLY
TO BRAUN NOTICED HOPPED. CO ONE
TIME PUBLIC HIM- SPEED USED OF-
THE IN A- AND GEO. BRONZE
POINTS. VERY VERY MINIMUS.
SEVEN TWENTY THE TOM ON THE TOP
YOU KNOW WHERE- NINETY ONE ONE
OF MILLION- TOM. TWO BETTER NOT.
THAN THE REST OF THE WAY HELLO
BUDGET MAIN. AND TO SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND. AHEAD OF US.
BRONSON'S TWO. SIDED A VERY SO
MANY TO PASS JEFF WILL PASS.
YEAH- I GUESS. MOVING FOR CALL
NOW KIND OF NEW THAT WAY. WERE
NEW HEARING THIS WHAT'S- DC BUT
YOU SAVE IN A- GAS COMBINE
CYCLE. YEAH JEFF. IS KNOW A
THREE AND A MILLION TIMES. CO.
TWO A POWERFUL- TONIGHT AND
THAT'S JUST THE NATURE OF THE
RESOURCES VERY- HIGH
TEMPERATURE QUALITY MINERALIZED-
RESOURCE. SIDE YEAH I DIRECTLY
FOR HIM EXTRACTION- OR-
RECOVERY. THIS TO CORRECTLY SO
THAT. YOU IT'S A VERY SMALL
PHYSICAL FOOTPRINT SUGGESTING
COULD TO G. THERE'S NO OPEN
MINING LOWER BACK RUSSIAN AT
ALL YEAH THE BRIAN FICK BECOME
FROM LIKE THE FEET BELOW TO
THIS SEA RESUL- AND AS YOU KNOW-
THESE PLANTS OF OPERATING FOR I
THIRTY AYE TEASED. AND VERY S.
JONATHAN ON A GUY. THE NIGHT
TIME AND SO EITHER PRICES HE
THAT'S A ONE- THE CHLORIDE AND
LITHIUM PART DROPPED THAT WILL
BE BEE GEES FROM THE VALLEY.
PLEASE BETTER GRAPHITE THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT SO WE DON'T NEED
TO A- AT TEN THOUSAND. A CARBON
FOOT TO SAY A SHIP LOAD OF ALL
ALPINE. HYDROPS SO AS I
MENTIONED PALATABLE I 1100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN STEAM AND
POWER THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IS
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
AND IT'S ALL GREAT- SO WILL
NEEDS. CO TWO EMISSIONS NOT
QUITE THERE BUT VERY CLOSE.
THEN FOR THE YOU KNOW WOULD
USES MINIMUM. YOU KNOW IT IS AS
JAY HAAS CHILD ON. YOU KNOW
THIS IS- A CLOSELY SYSTEM WAIT
WE HAVE WE SEE TO OUR MATHIS
THAT IS STAYING THAT IN THE CAN
SAVE IN THE PAGE DAY YEAH WILL
AS I AM WORKING ON CAPTURE SOME
OF THAT STATE BUT IT'S OF. MEAN
MORTY- COMPARED TO ANY TOPIC
PROP PRODUCTION OF COURSE YEAH
A BATTERY IN AND- WHAT I MEAN.
AND MAINTENANCE SAY TO FOR TO
EXPLORE OTHER CITIES NEED TO CA
LEAKING POD CYBER IS A BIG. TO
ASSAULT IT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
PRICES PER THAT IN THIS SACKS
CENTER TO JOHN PUT IT INTO IT
PUTTING KATHY WILL. IF THE
CATHODE PLAN MANY OF YEAH MAN
IF FOR. WAS TO LOCATE RIGHT
NEXT TO US WITH SEND UPON
THROUGH THE WALL INTO TERMS- SO
YOU COULD ALL OF THAT ALL OF
THE NEXT COST TO DO OF THAT.
THIS INDUSTRY JEFF SHOWS AND
HOW WILL. THIS COULD- ALL WORK
YOU KNOW X. ELECTRIC. WE SELL
INTO THE GREAT NOW THINK THAT'S
VERY WELCOME BY THE- YOUNG
AGAIN CITY'S. THIS ARE NOT HOST
EVERYONE WITH A PULLED OF
BISOLA HOW IT IS JOHN TOUCH ON
YOU KNOW WEEK READ THE- AND
THIS LARGE. SO THE YOU KNOW THE
BATHROOMS- AS MENTIONED
PRODUCED IN REAL TIME. THE
MINORITY PROCESS THROUGH ON
EXCHANGE TECH BE AROUND THIS
YEARS THE BATTERY FOR OF. IF IT
WAS ACTUALLY PRODUCING THE
WHOLE SECTOR OF
ENVIRONMENTALLY. FRIENDLY
SUPPLY CHAIN AND REMOVING
TWENTY LINKS FROM THAT SUPPLY
CHAIN AND TAXES AND EXCEPT WHEN
YOU HAVE TO EXPORT TO REPORT
AGAIN IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO
MAKE SENSE. SO YOU KNOW THE
LOCATION WHERE WE'RE LOCATED
YOU CAN SEE HERE THIS IS ON
ALSOP HELL'S KITCHEN SARGSYAN
THE SOLVENCY IN THE BACKGROUND
YOU CAN SAY THE- ISSUES WITH
DUST AND POLLUTANTS ON ANOTHER
THAT YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CASSIE OF THESE CRIED WORKABLE
YOU. WITH ASPIN WORKING HERE
FOR TEN YEARS WAS SAYING THESE
RESEDA. ASIDE FAST UP TO FORTY
YARDS A MONTH EXPOSING SOME
SOME SERIOUS- YEAH I Y. DUST.
ISSUES BUT ALSO EXPOSING A VERY
LARGE ONE OF THE WORLD'S
LARGEST IF NOT THE WORLD'S
LARGEST LITHIUM- GEOTHERMAL
BRINE RESOURCE SIDE AS WE
DEVELOP A MASTER PLAN THESE I
THINK TRY TO THINK ABOUT THIS
IN THE IMAGE OF THE BOTTOM
WHICH IS THE REGION ONE OF
BUSH'S PLANS. HELLO THEY'RE
VERY SMALL FOOTPRINT AGAIN THE
KIND OF LIKE I DID SORT OF-
FACTORIES AND FACILITIES IN AD
LAND AND HABITAT ALL CONTROL BE
MASTER PLAN A LITTLE BIT MORE
LIKE A SUBDIVISION THAN YOU
WOULD THINK OF. JUSTICE DAN
ONLINE FINANCES IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY I WOULD BE VERY
GOOD WHICH TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
ON THE ON THE BALLOT COMMISSION
AS A COMMISSIONER BUT ALSO.
YEAH WITH A CHAIR HOUSE CHILD'S
TAME A C. N. N. US D. W. WHILE
THE STATE WOULD BE VERY VERY
PROACTIVE IN THIS AND IT'S
QUITE AN EXCITING. OPPORTUNITY
TO SORT OF- TAKE ADVANTAGE AND
TRY TO. BRING SOMETHING UP.
GOOD AT OF THESE. SO I THINK
UNITED OF THE THOSE SORT OF
PATCH. OF COURSE INVEST IS A CO.
PERMITTING PROCESS A YOU SEE
THE IN TO THE THEY- IS VERY
COMPLEX IN THE SENSE WITH BY
FORGOT THE FADES- YOU KNOW THE
ACCORDING TO NEEDS- YEAH WITH
SIX SIGMA PROCESS AND- YEAH WE
ABSOLUTELY IT HE HAD ALL OF
THAT BUT I THINK THAT THEY SAID
THE OPPORTUNITIES. WHERE THE
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
ADMINISTRATIVE PROVE THAT COULD
APPROVING YOU SINGLE CATEGORY
TENSION COMMITTEE AND PROJECTS-
CERTAINLY ON THE TABLE FOR THE
BALLOT COMMISSION- YEAH THE C.
EQ AT FEDERAL LEVEL AT THE YEAH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CAN-CERTAINLY ASSIST WITH THAT.
THAT WOULD FAST TRACK-
CERTAINLY THE CORE RIGIDITIES.
IN THIS PROCESS AND MOVING
FORWARD.AND- YOU KNOW A LOT OF-
YEAH THE OPPORTUNITY-
OPPORTUNITY FOR ENTERPRISES ON
SO TO SPEAK I'VE BEEN ABOUT.
NOT JUST- THE STAND ALONE A GUY
IN THE TEAM PRODUCTION PLANT
BUT AN OVERRULE SECTOR IN
BUSINESS SAYS AS MR ROUGHEAD IS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW IT'S IMPROVE
VALUES OLD ABOUT THIS OF THESE
ORGANIC OPPORTUNITY HE NOW
WHERE WE'RE IN LOCATION
LOCATION LOCATION- WE HAVE
RAFEAL WE HAVE ROAD WITH.
INDUSTRIAL LAND YOU KNOW- WE
HAVE A VERY A RELIABLE WORK
FORCE AND THIS IS A NEW TAX
PRICE UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA.
NOTHING THAT HE ORDERED US AUTO
INDUSTRY IS CERTAINLY LOOKING
AT THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
AS WELL WE JUST NEED TO SORT
OF- ALIGNED. THE STYLES AND GET
GOING. SO JUSTIN IN. FINALIZE
THE MEN OUT. A LIABLE WILL-
EMPLOYEE INCLUDING CONSTRUCTION
JOBS JUST UNDER TWO THOUSAND
JOBS FULLY DEVELOPED. THAT'S
JUST US INTO A JOB TO TWO AND A
HALF THOUSAND. THAT EXCLUDES-
BATTERY MANUFACTURING SO I
THINK THERE'S A REAL PUSH FOR
THAT NOW AND THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT BUSINESS YOU KNOW ONE
OF THESE PLANS WOULD PLAY UP
TO. TWO TO THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. I WOULD PRODUCE A LOT
OF BY SLIDE- YEAH INDIRECT-
HOLD DIRECT ECONOMIC IMPACTS
FOR US YOU KNOW THAT THREE AND
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SIDE.
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
SIMILAR TO WHAT JONATHAN- IT'S
MENTIONED WE'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THAT ROLE WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
PART OF THAT. PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN PUBLIC- YEAH
COMMUNITY- THAT INVOLVEMENT IS
VERY VERY FIRST UP FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO THAT SIDE. WITH
THAT IDEA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO TAKE THANK
YOU MR CALL- WE WILL GO ON TO
THE NEXT PERCENT OR DEREK.
DEREK BENSON CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER OF ENERGY SOURCE WE
WILL SAVE QUESTIONS. FOR THE-
PANEL AFTER THIS LAST
PRESENTATION I THINK WE'RE
DOING GOOD TIME. JUST WANTED
TO- TAKE NOTE OF. THAT SO THANK
YOU THANKS FOR CENTER. GOOD
ACTORS ASSEMBLY GARCIA A MEMBER-
MY NAME IS THERE AND- CHIEF OP
ON. FOR ENERGY SOURCE MINERALS
AND- PRE SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. UP I THINK THE TO.
YOUR PREVIOUS SPEAKERS- COVERED
A LOT OF GROUND- I THINK I'LL
TAYLOR MINE TOO MAYBE COUPLE
LITTLE SUBTLE DIFFERENCES BUT I
THINK THERE'S A COMMON THEME-
HERE WITH WITH GEOTHERMAL-
BRIAN AS A AS A CERTAINLY AT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVANTAGE OVER
THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
INDUSTRY. A LITTLE BACKGROUND
ON ENERGY SOURCE MINERALS-
WE'RE BASED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE OPERATING
PERSONNEL HERE IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY- AS WELL AS SOME FOLKS
IN IN SAN DIEGO- WE WERE THE
DEVELOPER OF. THE U. S.
GEOTHERMAL FACILITY DOWN HERE
IN THE SOUTH AND SEE THAT'S THE
FEATHER STONE PLANT. WE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THAT
FACILITY. AND WE'VE ADDED- YOU
KNOW CAPACITY TO OUR TEAM AND
OUR DEVELOPING- YOU KNOW WHAT
WE BELIEVE WILL BE THE FIRST
PROJECT TO COMMERCIAL EXTRACT
WITH HIM FROM THAT GEOTHERMAL
BRINE. I THINK- BY JONATHAN
ROSS TOUCHED ON THIS AND PM G.
OF THE RYAN IS NEW- IT IS
COMPETE AND A GLOBAL GLOBAL
MARKET PLACE BUT I THINK THE
TECHNOLOGY- THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES I THINK BETWEEN
WHAT WE'RE PURSUING BUT I THINK
IT. AS A WHOLE- THIS WILL BE-
THE CLEANEST LITHIUM- AND
CERTAINLY OUR PROCESS WE'VE PUT
IT UP AGAINST- YOU KNOW THE
OTHER RESOURCES THROUGH. AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY- AND SO I'LL
SPEAK TO THAT HERE IN JUST A
SECOND BUT IS PART OF THIS
PROCESS I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S THAT'S INHERENT
AND ONE OF THE REAL ADVANTAGES
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE EXTRACTING.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF THERMAL ENERGY
OUT OF THE BRIAN TODAY- THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF ENERGY IN THAT
AND THAT REALLY DOES HELP DRIVE
TO. THE THE LITHIUM RECOVERY
PROCESS AND IT MAKES IT MORE
EFFICIENT- IF YOU'VE BEEN OUT
HERE AND HAVE YOU BEEN OUT HERE
YOU RECOGNIZE IT'S A PRETTY
SMALL- PROJECT FOOTPRINT- AND
IN FACT THE- THE WELL HEAD-
THAT PAT IS GENERALLY ABOUT.
YOU KNOW FIVE ACRES OR LESS SO
YOU KNOW THE PICTURES- THE
DESCRIPTION IN OR YOU HAVE AN
OPEN PIT MINE THAT SEVERAL
THOUSAND ACRES- AND EVAPORATION
POND THAT'S YOU KNOW. ON THE
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE OF YOU KNOW.
YEAH FIFTY A HUNDRED SQUARE
MILES- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY SMALL
FOOTPRINT- WHAT. WHAT I THINK
YOU'VE ALSO HEARD AND I'LL ECHO
THIS IS ONE OF. THE SALTON SEA
IS ONE OF THESE RARE RESOURCES
IN THE WORLD. WHERE YOU HAVE
GEOTHERMAL BRINE AND
COMMERCIALLY. VIABLE QUANTITY
OF LITHIUM AND THAT THAT JUST
DOESN'T EXIST IN A LOT OF
PLACES SO THERE UNITS
CALIFORNIA'S EXTREMELY
FORTUNATE AND I THINK IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR US HERE TO
ENERGY SOURCE MINERALS TO WHAT
I THINK MAKE IS THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE. AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY METHOD
OF MINING- LITHIUM SO WE
COMMISSION AN INDEPENDENT LIFE
CYCLE ASSESSMENT AND I THINK- A
LOT OF YOU WILL APPRECIATE.
THAT YOU KNOW THE TRANSITION TO
ELECTRIFICATION- YOU KNOW IS
INHERENTLY. A NET POSITIVE BUT
AT THE END- PRODUCT USERS ARE
ALSO LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT GOES INTO
ALL OF THEIR PRODUCTS AND
WHAT'S THAT WHAT'S THE
FOOTPRINT OF THAT WAS. SO WE
COMMISSION AN INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENT AND WE LOOK AT-
PARTICULARLY GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WATER USE AND THESE
LAND REQUIREMENTS. IN OUR
APPROACH SPECIFICALLY- YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE SPENT A LOT OF YEARS
DOING OUR OUR PILOT WORK. OF
ENGINEERING AND- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE ADMISSION RATES-
FROM OUR PROJECT- UP AGAINST
THESE HARD ROCK RESOURCES WERE
ABOUT 90% LOWER SO FULL ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE LOWER ON
EMISSIONS- WE LOOK AT WATER
USE- IT'S THE SAME. YOU KNOW A
FULL ORDER OF MAGNITUDE AND A
90% REDUCTION COMPARED TO
EXISTING TECHNOLOGIES. AND
THEN- WHEN WE LOOK AT AND
COMPARE OURSELVES TO SOME OTHER-
SELECTIVE LITHIUM EXTRACTION
TECHNOLOGIES- WE HAVE A
TECHNIQUE AND A METHOD THAT'S
THAT'S EXTREMELY EFFICIENT WITH
RESPECT TO- THAT WATER USE- AS
WELL AS REAGENT CONSUMPTION AND
ENERGY. AND SO- YOU KNOW I
THINK THE MESSAGE HERE YOU KNOW
I SORT OF ECHOES THE GROUP BUT
ALSO TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER AND
SAY YOU KNOW WE FOUND A WAY TO
MAKE THIS IS JUST AS EFFICIENT.
AS POSSIBLE AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- BOTH
ECONOMICALLY BUT
ENVIRONMENTALLY YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A PROCESS THAT'S IT'S GOT
THE YOU KNOW THE LOWEST INPUTS-
POSSIBLE PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO ENERGY. SO AGAIN I
YOU KNOW I CAN'T EMPHASIZE THAT
YOU KNOW THIRTY ACRE PROJECT
SIZE YOU KNOW VERSUS A HARD
ROCK OPERATION IT MIGHT BE
THREE THOUSAND ACRES OR UPON
EVAPORATION PROCESS LIKE THOSE
IN SOUTH AMERICA WHICH WOULD BE
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THIRTY
THOUSAND. ACRES OR MORE SO.
YEAH WE DEFINITELY AGREE
ELECTRIFICATION OF
TRANSPORTATION CAN DELIVER SOME
REAL ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS TO
QUIT THAT POWER IS RENEWABLE
LIKE WE HAVE YOUR RIGID
THERMAL. AND IF THOSE BATTERY
MATERIAL FEEDSTOCKS ARE SOURCED
FROM THE MOST SUSTAINABLE
RESOURCE TYPE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT'S GEOTHERMAL. LITHIUM AND
IT LEADS YOU KNOW I THINK IN
EVERY ENVIRONMENTAL METRIC YOU
KNOW BY HEAD AND SHOULDERS. BUT
OTHERS HAVE ECHOED IT- LEVINE
IS GLOBALLY COMPETITIVE WE'RE
COMPETING ON PRICE WE'RE
COMPETING ON PRODUCT QUALITY.
BATTERY CPAC WITHIN HYDROXIDE
OR LITHIUM CARBONATE- IS NOT A
COMMODITY CHEMICAL LIKE SOME
MIGHT HAVE YOU BELIEVE IT IS
IT'S A VERY BESPOKE- PRODUCT.
AND IT'S VERY HARD TO MAKE- IT
REQUIRES A LOT OF QUALITY
CONTROL. AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
COMPETING WITH FOLKS THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE VARIOUS SHADES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL CHARACTER AND SO
IT'S- IT'S DEFINITELY
CHALLENGING MARKET. AND ONE
WHERE YOU COMPETING ON ON EVERY
METRIC. MANY OF YOU KNOW IT
WILL COME A SURPRISE YOU KNOW
CONSTRUCTION COSTS OPERATING
COSTS IN THE US ARE GOING TO BE
HIGHER THAN MUCH OF THE WORLD.
pAND IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE LOOK
AT IT YOU KNOW THAT THAT JUST
PUTS AN EXTRA CHALLENGE ON US
TO BE AS EFFICIENT AS WE CAN
AND THAT'S RELATED TO ENERGY
RELATES TO WATER. UTILIZING THE
MOST EFFICIENT TECHNOLOGIES AND
GETTING THE LITHIUM RECOVERY IS
AS HIGH AS WE CAN FROM A FROM A
GIVEN PROJECT AND SO. THAT'S
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S THE
PACKAGE WE'RE BRINGING TO THE
SALTON SEA- YOU KNOW TO BE SORT
OF THE BEST STEWARD OF THE
RESOURCE- AND PRODUCE THE BEST
PRODUCT WE CAN. TO COMPETE IN A
AND A AND A BALLING. YOU KNOW
BATTERY MARKET- I THINK. YOU
GIVE ME A SENSE OF SCALE I
THINK NOMINALLY OUR PROJECT IS.
TWENTY THOUSAND TONNES PER
ANNUM- YOU KNOW JOHNSON
SPEAKING OF THEIR THEIR
FACILITIES ARE. YOU KNOW ORDER
MAGAZINE MAYBE ABOUT SIX TIMES
THE BRIAN SO BRIAN FLOWING
TODAY'S YOU KNOW WELL OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TIMES- FOR
YEAR OF BATTERY GRADE-
DILITHIUM- CARBONATE EQUIVALENT
AND- YEAH THAT'S THAT'S A
GLOBAL RESOURCE. TODAY BUT
THOSE THOSE NUMBERS ARE YOU
KNOW EXPECTED SHIP. AND DEMAND
FOR LITHIUM IS YOU KNOW
INCREASING. YOU KNOW TO WELL
OVER A MILLION TONS BY THE
TWENTY. TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY TIME FRAME SO IT'S- IT'S
A HUGE MARKET AND- I THINK.
EVERY RESOURCE MATTERS AND I
THINK IT'S A SPECIALLY TREATED
GET. SOMETHING WITH HIM AND
SAID THAT- RATHER THAN MAYBE
REHASH SOME OF THE OTHER TOPICS
BECAUSE I THINK THE FIRST YOU
GUYS COVERED A LOT OF THE- THE
MATERIAL WELL. I THINK IT JUST
MAYBE WANT TO CLOSE HERE. BY
SAYING- YOU KNOW THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE INDUSTRY THUS FAR. BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
GOVERNOR-BROWN-SIGNS-MOORLACH-DATE-SEPARATION-BILL.
ALLOWING THE C. C. EACH ISSUE
ITS FIRST GRANT TO PROMOTE
ADVANCED LITHIUM EXTRACTION-
GOVERNOR BROWN- SIGNING MESSAGE
THEN ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
LITHIUM EXTRACTION AND- I THINK
YOU COULD HAVE BEEN MORE RIGHT-
AND AS THE VALUE AND IMPORTANCE
OF LOOKING AT SELLING GROUND WE
WERE ONE OF THE BENEFICIARIES
OF THAT IT EARLY ENGINEERING.
GRANT MONIES- WE PUT THAT TO
GREAT USE YOU KNOW WE'VE FULLY
ENGINEERED YOU KNOW OUR
FACILITY CONTINUED ADVANCE THAT
THAT PROJECT- BUT IT CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW HELPED US- YOU KNOW
EARLY AND EARLY IN OUR EFFORT-
AND WE CONTINUE TO CHECK A
BAT'S SO. AGAIN I THINK
IMPORTANT REALLY EMPHASIZED
THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S WITHIN RESOURCE.
FROM THE SALTON SEA IT IS IT IS
A COMPLETELY. DIFFERENT
RESOURCE TYPE AND A COMPLETELY
ENVIRONMENT COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL. FOOT
PRINT OF THAT WHAT YOU SEE FROM
THE STATE OF THE INDUSTRY. AND
IN SOUTH AMERICA AND IN WESTERN
AUSTRALIA AND I THINK AS A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT- YOU KNOW
TAKE COMFORT IN THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW IT CAN BE DONE BETTER
AND- HERE. WE DEFINITELY INTEND
TO DO THAT. SO THAT THANK YOU
AND- HAVE ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER BRANSON AND-
THE TO FIRE- SPEAKERS. AT THIS
I THINK- HAS BEEN VERY
INFORMATIVE CONNECTED A NUMBER
OF DOTS. I WOULD HOPE IN TERMS
OF- MANY OF THE QUESTIONS A
WESTERLY. AND PERHAPS SOME
REMAINING QUESTIONS- THAT
EXISTS ALL LAST ALL OPEN UP TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR. OTHER
QUESTIONS. YOU MENTIONED
THERE'S A STRIP MINE AND
EVAPORATION PONDS. IT'S
EXTRACTED THROUGH THE PRIME.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO HOW DOES
THAT THE LITHIUM YOU GET OUT OF
THE PRIME WITHOUT. EVAPORATION
POND. NOT ADMISSIBLE IT
SOMEWHERE. UNDER THE THOUGHT
ABOUT LOVE. YOU KNOW LIKE A
FINE IS THERE STILL LET'S SEE
IF IT'S STILL IN MY REMARKS ON
BUT IT IS IT'S HOW DO YOU GET
IT OUT OF THE PIPE THAT'S WATER
FLOWING THROUGH THE PARK. THIS
NOT SHOW. THEIR DANCING HERE I
CAN I CAN SPEAK THERE'S A
COUPLE TECHNOLOGIES BOTH BEING
TALKED ABOUT HERE CONSULTANCY.
WE IS A HIGHLY SELECTIVE WITH
THE OF THE ADS ARE MEANT TO
PREFERENTIALLY PULL WITH THE
ABOUT OF LATE AT THE BRYANT- SO
THAT IS ONE METHOD I AN
EXCHANGE- DO IT WITH A- AYE ON
REPLACEMENT- METHOD- BUT
BASICALLY- WHAT. THE CATEGORY
OF TECHNOLOGIES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE PREFERENTIALLY
SELECT LITHIUM- OUT OF THE
FLUID- THROUGH PASSING IT OVER
MEDIA THAT IS- THIS EITHER IT'S
OR MATT OR AYE EXCHANGE MEDIA.
THAT PULLS A LIFT HIM OUT AND
SO- IT IT IT SIMULTANEOUSLY
WILL REJECT THE SODIUM THE
CALCIUM AND OTHER MONOVALENT
DIVALENT- I ON SO IF YOU LOOK
AT YOUR PERIODIC TABLE YOU KNOW
LITHIUM'S ON THE FAR LEFT AT
THE VERY TOP- THE REST OF THOSE
SODIUM CALCIUM MAGNESIUM ARE
ALL. CLOSELY RELATED AND NEAR
THEM CARE ACT TABLE LISTA
SUMMARILY REJECTED AS YOU PASS
THROUGH THIS THIS MEDIA SO IT'S
A BIT OF ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT'S- YOU
KNOW IT'S A TECHNIQUE THAT'S
USED- IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
INDUSTRY APPLICATIONS IT WOULD
JUST HAPPEN TO BE TALKING
ABOUT. LITHIUM HERE BUT YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S WATER
SOFTENING OR- YOU KNOW WATER
TREATMENT FACILITIES OR WHAT
HAVE YOU IT IT BUILDS ON THAT-
THAT TECHNOLOGY BASED. I'M NOT
SURE WHO MIGHT ANSWER THIS
BECAUSE IT BUT LITHIUM VALLEY
AS AN OVERLAY. OF THE SALTON
SEA. ARE IN PERIL COUNTY. THE
WHEREABOUTS IS IT
GEOGRAPHICALLY BECAUSE I KNOW
THEY ARE REAL WELL BUT I. URGE
YOU JUST AREN'T WE COME UP WITH
THE NAME AND WE'RE CALLING IT
LITHIA VALLEY BECAUSE IT'S TO
THE WEST TO THE EAST THE SALTON
SEA. THAT THAT WAS JUST TRYING
TO GET OUT OF A GEOGRAPHICAL.
MAP IN MY MIND ON THAT ONE. I
THINK I THINK WE GIVE CREDIT TO
DAVID HOPE SHE'LL FOR THAT ONE-
THIS WAS ORIGINALLY SORT OF A
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION. ON
LITHIUM AND THEN I THINK I
THINK THAT THE CHAIR GETS
CREDIT FOR TURNING INTO A WITH
THE ENVELOPES. IT'S THE YOU
CAN'T FIND IT ON A MAP. KNOWN
RISK IT IS GENERALLY AT
IMPERIAL VALLEY. KELLY AREA-
THE GEOTHERMAL FACILITIES THAT
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT FROM
THE THREE OF US. ARE LOCATED
ADJACENT TO THE SALTON SEA. IN
THE LOWER. SHALL EASTERN
CORNER. OF THE STREET SO THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH THE LITHIUM VALLEY.
AREA AND I THINK. I THINK IT'S
A GOOD OF BRANDING NAME
BECAUSE- WE GOT SO WE CAN
VALLEY IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AND I THINK. WITHIN BELIZE KIND
OF A GOOD NAME. BUT NO IT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN OKAY WELL WE'LL
GIVE THE CHAIR THAT BUT THAT'S
WHAT I NEEDED TO KNOW BECAUSE
I'VE TOWARD SOLVENCY. I'VE BEEN
ALL OUT THERE SEEING THE OF.
THE THERMAL. OF PLANTS. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT DID CONSTRUCTION
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS I
ACTUALLY WORKED OUT THERE AND
DO SOME CONCRETE WORK. BACK IN
MY YOUNGER YOUNGER DAYS. OVER
THAT BUT THE OTHER PART IS DONE
I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
IT TORN DOWN HERE. COOPER
FIRMLY LIKE YOU SAID A HUNDRED
SEVEN I KNOW TO GET UP TO A
HUNDRED TWENTY SO WE'RE GONNA
DO THE TIMING PRETTY QUICK WHEN
WE DO THAT SO IT MIGHT BE IN
NOVEMBER MIGHT BE A CHRISTMAS
PRESENT FOR US IN OUR OFF TIME
BUT- I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
TOUR. THANK TAKE IS A MEMBER
QUESTIONS WAS FROM TH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- IN REGARDS TO
THE- THE ENVIRONMENT AND THEN
STAKEHOLDER INPUT IN THE AREA.
I KNOW THAT IN THE SALTON SEA
AREA THERE'S- TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THERE HAS
THERE BEEN OUT REACH AND
DISCUSSION WITHIN THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AS FAR AS- LOOKING
AT AND WE TALKED ABOUT
REGULATIONS AND PERMITS IN THE
STATE IS ONE. OF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALSO ONE ASPECT
OF IT SO HAS THERE BEEN OUT
REACH AT LEAST DIALOGUE GOING
ON WITH THEM LOCAL TRIBES IN
THE AREA OF NOW. WHAT WE'RE
CALLING THE LITHIUM VALLEY.
THERE THE LICKING VALLEY
COMMISSION I DON'T HAVE IT AT
MY FINGERTIPS BUT OF THE
FOURTEEN MEMBERS I BELIEVE TO-
OR WITH TRIBES ONE IS TOWARDS
MARTINEZ AND I'M I'M SORRY I'M
BLANKING ON THE OTHER- WHEN WE
HAD OUR VIRTUAL TOWN HOLD WE
DID INVITE. OTHER TRIBAL
GROUPS- I'M ACTUALLY BASED IN
WASHINGTON DC AND SPEND A LOT
OF TIME AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY ON CAPITOL HILL. TALKING
ABOUT LITHIUM RECOVERY- BECAUSE
THE TRIBAL GROUPS ARE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY THE TORTOISE MARTINEZ
TRIBE ACTUALLY. IS LOCATED WHAT
KIND OF DIAGONALLY ACROSS THE
SOLVENCY IN THE NORTHWESTERN
CORNER. BUT THEY ALSO HAVE.
HAPPEN TO BE UNDER THE
SCHULTZI- BUT ANYWAY YES
THERE'S A LOT OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT NOT JUST WITH THE
TRIBAL GROUPS. OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS AS
WELL. THE REASON I'M ASKING IS
BECAUSE- THROUGHOUT HISTORY
THERE'S BEEN A DIFFERENT
EXTRACT OF MINE'S DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT HAVE BECAUSE-
DETRIMENT ENVIRONMENTAL- HEALTH
HAZARDS THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IN THE IN THE FOREFRONT OF THE
DISCUSSION. THAT WERE- DRESSING
THOSE NEEDS IN THOSE CONCERNS
ARE BEING HEARD- I'VE HEARD IN
THE DIFFERENT PANEL
DISCUSSIONS. OF HOW TECHNOLOGY
HAS NOW MOVED FORWARD TO-
CREATE MINIMAL EFFECT TO SOME
OF THOSE- ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
BUT- LIKE MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
HERE TOO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
MORE OF THAT AND HOW THAT'S
GOING TO PLAY OUT NOW WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE. AND
CONCERNED MAKING SURE THAT
VOICE IS AT THE TABLE OF THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES AND THAT
PAST HISTORIES ARE GOING TO BE
REPEATED AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THIS DISCUSSION. R. WELL I
THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL THREE
OF US BY THE WAY IT'S THE QUE
HAN INDIAN TRIBE IS THE OTHER
IT JUST SLIPPED MY MIND. BUT
LET ME LET ME PUT THIS IN
CAPITALISTIC TERMS AS
DEVELOPERS WE HAVE TO DE RISK
ARE PROJECTS. AND ONE OF THE
WAYS YOU DE RISK AS YOU ENGAGE
THE COMMUNITY YOU ARE
TRANSPARENT YOU LET THEM KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IT'S NOT JUST
FIRING IT'S EXPLAINING YOUR
TECHNOLOGY LIKE WE'RE DOING
HERE. IT'S ENGAGING THAT
COMMUNITY IT'S EXPLAINING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASPECTS I THINK
CHAIRMAN HOPE SHE'LL MAKE THE
POINT AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING- YOU KNOW YOU LOOK
AT. LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
EXTRACTIVE MINERALS WHETHER
IT'S THE CONGO OR OR OTHER
PLACES AROUND THE WORLD
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES. I HAVE BEEN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF. THAT CAN'T
HAPPEN HERE. AND I THINK THAT
WHAT WHAT ALL OF US ARE LOOKING
TO DO CERTAINLY SPEAKING FOR MY
COMPANY BUT I KNOW FOR ANYONE
ELSE WANTING TO DEVELOP IN THE
AREA. IS FULL COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT- AND FULL DISCLOSURE
FOLDERS TRANSPARENCY. LOCAL
HIRING- AND THE LIGHT WHETHER
IT'S TRIBAL GROUPS OR OTHERS
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC. IS A GOOD
QUESTION TO THE DEN GAS STOVES-
TWO TRIBES SEE FORT YUMA
CONFRONT INDIAN TRIBE. FIRST
MARTINEZ. A TRIBE WERE BOTH
APPOINTEES OF THE CVC PROCESS
TO THE- COMMISSION AND WE'RE
GLAD THAT THEY ARE. AT THE
TABLE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU SO
MUCH. TO ALL THREE OF YOU WHO
HAVE PRESENTED TODAY WE ARE
VERY. GLAD THAT- WE WERE ABLE
TO HIGHLIGHT. OF THE LITHIUM
VALLEY CONCEPT AND THE AS A
GOVERNMENTS A REAL TIME
ACTIVITIES GOING ON. IN THE
REGION- WE HEARD EARLIER IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE STATE CAN DO
TO HELP ADVANCE THESE EFFORTS-
I GOT A GOOD. OF COMMENT FROM
OUR CHAIR OF TRANSPORTATION IN
THE ASSEMBLY WHO'LL I WAS
INTRIGUED BY YOU KNOW THE
PRESENTATIONS SHE GOT TO HEAR
AND WANTS TO BE. A SUPPORTIVE
AS SHE AS SHE MENTIONED THAT ON
OUR WAY. OUT BUT THAT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE NEXT-
PANELED AND FINAL PANEL AND-
THIS WILL HAVE TO DO WITH THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. A VERY TIED TO THE
LAST SET OF QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE. I
STICK AROUND SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS MIGHT COME UP THAT TO
YOU MAY BE ABLE TO ASSIST US
WITH. BUT AT THIS TIME WHY ASK
OUR OUR FIRST PRESENTER FOR
THIS FINAL PANEL STILL BE A
POLICY IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ON THE OUTSIDE. AND THE CHAIR
OF THE LITTLE VALLEY COMMISSION
SHE WOULD BE FOLLOWED BY DR
MARTA GARCIA PRESIDENT OF THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY COLLEGE- PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU. GARCIA AND-
TO YOUR COLLEAGUE SAW FIRST I
WANNA REALLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LEADERSHIP THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA HAS BROAD- IN ELEVATING.
A REGION IN THE SALTON SEA AREA
THAT HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
IGNORED AND SOMETIMES FELT AS A
RELEVANT TO SACRAMENTO- AND
ALSO THANKS TO THE COLLEAGUES
HIS COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED HIM BY EMBRACING THE
VALUES OF EQUITY INCLUSION AND
SUSTAINABILITY. AND IN DOING SO
REALIZING THE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY IN THE SALTON SEA
REGION- LIKE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED- NOT ONLY DO
Y. CHAIR THAT ANYTHING ABOUT
THE COMMISSION. BUT I'M ALSO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT. THAT HAS BEEN
WORKING ALONGSIDE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IN- EQUITABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TODAY I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A BRIEF INTRODUCTION
TO THE MEETING ABOUT THE
COMMISSION. ITS WORK AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCLUSIVE
AUTHENTIC COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
AS A NEW INDUSTRY IS BORN IN
THE IMPERIAL. AND COACHELLA
VALLEYS- I'D WE HAVE HEARD
RIGHT THE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE LEAD THE-
BEING A BY PRODUCT OF GEO
THERMAL OF GIFTS AS A LOT OF
ADVANTAGE IN THE POTENTIAL-
COMMERCIALIZATION. OF LEAD THEM
AND I BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE
SOME OF THE REASONS WHY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA AUTHORED
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
CREATED THE LEADING ABOUT THE
COMMISSION SO THAT WE CAN STOP
TALKING ABOUT. THE SALTON SEA'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY POTENTIAL AND
INSTEAD CRAFT A ROAD MAP. TO
THAT END SO THAT HE CAN VALLEY
COMMISSION IS TASKED WITH
REVIEWING INVESTIGATING AND
ANALYZING THE POTENTIAL ISSUES
AND POTENTIAL INCENTIVES
REGARDING BEAT THEM EXTRACTION
AND ITS USE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
COMMISSION IS COMPOSED OF
FOURTEEN MEMBERS THAT WERE
APPOINTED BY A COMBINATION OF
THE CC THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES- THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER AND
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND AS
SUCH THE MEMBERSHIP IS DIVERSE
AND IT REPRESENTS THE INDUSTRY-
GOVERNMENT NATIVE AMERICAN.
GROUPS NONPROFITS. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS.
THE WAY THAT ICE THE TASK
BEFORE THE LEVY VALLEY
COMMISSION HOWEVER IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT HOW WE DEVELOP AND
GETTING THEM TO MARKET BUT HOW
DO WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
SUSTAINABLE. AND WITH DIRECT
BENEFITS TO THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING THE SALTON SEA. AND
WE CANNOT ACHIEVE THIS IF WE
APPROACH LEAD THEM DEVELOPMENT.
AS BUSINESS AS USUAL WHERE THE
BENEFITS ARE REAPED BY A FEW
AND BUILT ON LOW WAGES ARE POOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS. AS
HAS BEEN RECOGNIZING COMMENTS
DURING THIS CONVERSATION WITH
HIM IS ABOUT MORE THAN THE
ENVIRONMENT. IT'S ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF OUR ECONOMY AND FOR
THE LOCAL REGION WHICH HAS BEEN
INEXPLICABLY HIT BY THE COLD
AND DEMOCRATS IT'S ALSO ABOUT
RECOVERY AND HAVING A CHANCE AT
IT. SO WHAT SHOULD OUR NEW
APPROACH BEING LEAD THEM
DEVELOPMENT CANNOT HAPPEN BY
ONLY HELLO ADDRESSING THE
LEGISLATIVE BARRIERS THAT
TECHNOLOGY INTHE SCIENCE WHICH
ARE ALL IMPORTANT- BUT BY
ADDRESSING THEM TOGETHER WITH
THE COMMUNITY. AS AN EXAMPLE
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY THAT LEAD
THEM DEVELOPMENT WILL CREATE
HIGH ROAD SHOPS BUT IT'S
ANOTHER TO BE INTENTIONAL IN
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF OUR
EXISTING WORKFORCE. THIS CAN
ONLY BE DONEBY ENGAGING OUR
RESIDENTS TO LEARN ABOUT THE
BARRIERS THAT THEY FACE IN
ACHIEVING ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND
CALL CREATING PATHWAYS THAT
WILL ADVANCE. ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES RATHER THAN
IMPORTING LABOR. AS A LEADING
VALLEY COMMISSION EXPLORE
CENTER LIBERATES
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE VARIOUS
ELEMENTS OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
FLEET THEM. SUCH AS THE MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
AND INCENTIVES. WE WANT TO BE
CONSCIOUS ABOUT CREATING A
PRODUCT ACTIS DAD WILL ENGAGE
THE COMMUNITY IN IDENTIFYING.
THE NEEDS. AS A THOROUGH NINE
RIGHT SO WHAT DOES COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT LOOK LIKE WHEN WE
ARE DISCUSSING BENEFITS WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE WHEN IT IS AS
WE'RE DISCUSSING ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. AND MAKING SURE AGAIN
THAT WE HAVE THAT PRACTICE SO
THAT WE'RE IDENTIFYING WITH THE
COMMUNITY THE VERY IS- MEANS.
NOT JUST OF THE REPAIRMEN ITS
DEVELOPMENT BUT THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY AND THERE IS SOME
OVERLAP IN SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE ALREADY
HAD- WE'VE IDENTIFIED FOR
EXAMPLE BARRIERS SURROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE- FOR AT LEAST
THE- AND IT'S AND THE ABILITY
TO BUILD A SUPPLY CHAIN IN THIS
REGION. WELL THOSE SAME
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS ARE
PROBLEMS THAT OUR COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN FACING AND ADVOCATING TO
IMPROVE FOR MANY YEARS- LAKE
ROAD ST ACCESS TO BROADBAND AND
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND SOME
OF THE EXAMPLES. SO WE NEED TO
LOOK BEYOND OUR TRADITIONAL
PARTNERS. AND ENGAGE THE
MEMBERS OF THE IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES IN MOVING THIS
DEVELOPMENT ALONG SIDE US. I
THANK EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY THREE-
WHICH IS AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA GETS
SAYS- CLOSER IN THAT DIRECTION
BY AUTHORIZING THE USE OF
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS
THROUGH A SUSTAINED ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- HAS DEDICATED RESOURCES
FOR THE TYPE OF REGIONAL LEAD
COMMUNITY PLAN MEANS THAT IS
NEEDED IN ORDER FOR US TO
REALLY ACHIEVE- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN A WAY THAT IS
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE AND
THAT UNDERSTANDS THE NEEDS AND
THE LOCAL CONTEXT OF OUR REGION.
SO I WILL LEND WITH THIS WHILE
THE LEADING VALLEY COMMISSION
IS DIRECTED TO ANALYZE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HOW TO
SUPPORT ITS DEVELOPMENT. THIS
TASK SYSTEM THE CONTEXT OF A
COMMUNITY THAT FEELS THAT THE
STATE HAS UNDER DELIVERED ON
CHALLENGES RELATED TO THE
SALTON SEA. WHICH BRINGS
TOGETHER PUBLIC HEALTH ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES IF WE
CANNOT DEMONSTRATE THAT THE TEN
YEAR RESTORATION PLAN FOR THE
SALTON SEA CAN ACHIEVE THE
MULTI BENEFITS DESCRIBED IN THE
STATE'S THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE. AND LEVERAGE OTHER
STATE INVESTMENTS AS WELL AS
THE FEDERAL BUILD BACK BETTER
COMMITMENTS TO MEET OUR
COMMUNITY'S NEEDS. I DON'T SEE
HOW WE TELL THE PUBLIC THAT IT
WILL BE DIFFERENT WHEN WE GET
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF ANYTHING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU. A DOCTOR MARTHA
GARCIA- WILL BE OUR NEXT BEAKER
WE'RE DOING A GOOD ON TIME
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME TIME FOR
SOME QUESTIONS AS WELL HERE AS
IT RELATES TO COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SO- PLEASE A STATE
STAY WITH US. DR MARGARET MARTA
GARCIA PLEASE- PLEASE PROCEED.
YOUR TIME MAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON. I ALSO ALONG WITH
THE OVER HERE WITH US EXPRESS
TREMENDOUS GRATITUDE TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND YOUR ADVOCACY OF
THIS COMMUNITY IMPERIAL COUNTY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN PUBLIC COMMUNITY.
COLLEGE PRESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. LIPKIN PRESENTS AN
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR NOT
ONLY FOR IMPROVE COUNTY BUT
ALSO THE QUESTION ABOUT ONLY IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. IT PRESENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER AS
A RESIDENT OF A DRUG CAL ME AS
SOMEONE THAT WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN THIS COMMUNITY AS
SOMEONE NOT GRADUATED FROM POLY
COLLEGE THIS INDUSTRY
REPRESENTS HOPE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY IT REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT NOT ONLY FOR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT THERE WILL BE OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR COMMUNITY TO- OBVIOUSLY
THROUGH EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUTE TO
CONTINUE TO. DEVELOP AND AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY I WILL FOCUS ON SOME
OF THE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AS THERE HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIAL
COMMENTS ON THE BENEFITS OF
LITHIUM UP THAT ARE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN PROVIDED. WE HAVE
AS STATED BY MR MY SCHOOL- STE.
STARTED THE DISCUSSION IN
REGARDS TO CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT'S NECESSARY
TO PREPARE THE FUTURE
WORKFORCE- AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT SOME OF THE EXPERIENCE AND
KNOWLEDGE THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY WILL BE RELATED TO
ENGINEERING SUCH AS MECHANICAL
INDUSTRIAL FABRICATION A LOT
AND ELECTRICAL ENGINEERING I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU ALL THAT
WE ARE- FINALIZING A
PARTNERSHIP WHICH SITE THESE.
UNIVERSITY WHICH IS. LOCATED IN
MEXICALI I ASKED WE ARE A
COMMUNITY THAT OBVIOUSLY RELY
ON EACH OTHER MUTUALLY MEXICO
AND- AND IMPERIAL COUNTY H. SO
WE ARE CREATING AN ENGINEERING
TALKS WAY- AND IT'S ONE OF MANY
OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS HOWEVER IT
IS AN OPTION THAT WILL BE LOCAL
WE- ARE PROVIDED. FOR THOSE
THAT EXPERIENCE BARRIERS TO
RELOCATING- BUT PLANT OPERATION
WE NOW IN ITS KEY WELDING
FABRICATION- I UNDERSTAND YEP
TECHNOLOGY SPECIALLY AS THE
EQUIPMENT- THAT IS WILL BE
UTILIZED- SOME OF IT REQUIRES.
THAT EMPLOYEES ARE
KNOWLEDGEABLE IN AND TECHNOLOGY
SPECIALLY AUTOMATION-
INSTRUMENTATION. ADMINISTRATIVE
AND ACCOUNTING. SO AS I STATED
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
INDUSTRY WILL CONTINUE WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND IMPROPER COUNTY AND THE
SURROUNDING REGION- I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU ABOUT. PAYROLL
VALLEY COLLEGE PREVIOUSLY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THEY DO A GRANT
THAT WOULD SUPPORT AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION AS
WE WERE PREPARING DISPLACED
WORKERS- THAT WERE. BEING ARE
TRAINED TO WORK AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY. WE'RE READY TO DO THAT
AGAIN- WE ARE COMMITTED. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IN THIS
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BETTERMENT OF
OUR COMMUNITY HOLISTICALLY WE
MUST WORK TOGETHER WE MUST DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES- TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITY. AND I SINCERELY
BELIEVE DOT. AS THE DISCUSSION
WITH HELP THIS AFTERNOON AND%
THAT'S THE COMMITMENT THAT IS
REFLECTED CHIU UP CONTRIBUTE
CHIU RECOVERY NOT ONLY OF THIS
COMMUNITY KATELLA VALLEY
COMMUNITY AT THE STATE- THAT WE
COULD DO IT COLLECTIVELY THAT
THIS. OF LITHIUM THIS INDUSTRY
I WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL
CONTRIBUTOR TO IMPROVE COUNTY
BECOMING THE CAPITAL OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY SO I'M
COMMITTED ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND PROPEL
THE COLLEGE WE ARE HERE AS A
PARTNER TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN.
TO PREPARE THE FUTURE WORKFORCE
A BIT. OF THIS DENTISTRY THANK
YOU. I YOU VERY MUCH A DOCTOR
GARCIA AND- THIS WILL BE A BOSS
I'M GONNA ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
REGARDING YOUR PRESENTATIONS
ANY OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED. AND AT THIS POINT I
THINK SOME DEMOCRATS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MY QUESTION IS- I
BELIEVE PRESIDENT GARCIA WITH
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY COLLEGE UP
MISS GARCIA CAN YOU PLEASE
SHARE WITH US MAYBE SOME OF
THE- OPPORTUNITIES WITH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
YOUR COLLEGE IS CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING AND WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES MAY LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE. IF THE PROJECTS-
FOR MORE OPPORTUNITIES RELATED
TO LITHIUM WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH I
KNOW PERSONALLY PLACE A HUGE A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE WITH UPWARD
MOBILITY ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS.
AT GOOD UNION JOBS AT THAT
POINT ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
AFFILIATED WITH- AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND WHAT
THAT CURRENTLY LOOKS LIKE FOR
YOUR COLLEGE. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTION SO CURRENTLY WE
DO HAVE AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IN- ELABORATION WITH
ID. IN ADDITION DISTRICT- WHEN
IT COMES WHERE I SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY THE COLLEGE. IS
DEVELOPING PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS- ALSO WE ARE IN THE IN
THE- PARTNER AND WORK CLOSELY
WITH I. B. W. WHICH IS THE
ELECTRICAL UNION. FOR US BUT I
ENVISION AND IT'S AMAZING TO BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION UP
TODAY BECAUSE WE WERE ABOUT TO
HIRE AT JUSTICES WERE ABOUT TO
HIRE- AND ENGINEER WHEREABOUTS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FACULTY
AND WHEN IT COMES TO RELATING-
AND UNDERSTANDING. THE NEED FOR
SPAM. COULD BE INCORPORATED
INTO THESE POSITIONS- I SEE AND
A VERY IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO CREATE NOT FOR CREDIT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THESE
COMPANIES WILL NEED ARE IN
PLACE TO BE PREPARED IN A
SHORT- THE- TERM OF PERIOD TO
CREATE AND A NOT FOR CREDIT-
PROGRAM THAT INCORPORATES ALL
THESE COMPONENTS AND ADDS A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP. BROKE GROUND IT
WOULD BE. EASIER FOR US FOR US
TO CREATE IT IN A SHORTER TIME
PERIOD AND TO AND TO TAILOR IT
TO THE NEEDS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF THE INDUSTRY- SO. WE'RE IT
IS. AND WE'RE GONNA DO WHATEVER
IT TAKES BECAUSE THIS COMMUNITY
DESERVES THAT AND- AND I KNOW
THAT MY FACULTY IS COMMITTED
AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE HIRING
THE FACULTY THAT HAS THE
EXPERTISE TO SERVE THE NEEDS OF
THIS SPECIFIC INDUSTRY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR THAT
RESPONSE I'M GOING TO BUILD
BUILDING QUESTION OKAY GOT SOME
RUNS THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SORRY FOR THE DELAYED
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION BUT
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS-
WORKING WITH- IMPERIAL VALLEY
COLLEGE- IF YOU'RE IN A PRIME
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO PUT OUT
TO THE COMMUNITY. AND DISPEL-
ANY MIRRORS OR- MISCONCEPTIONS
OF WHAT THE PROJECT AND HOW THE
PROJECTS MOVING FORWARD-
MEANING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT THE MINIMAL IMPACT NEW
TECHNOLOGY I'M HOPING THAT THE-
THE COLLEGE WILL BE ABLE TO
LEAD THAT EFFORT WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. TO BE ABLE TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST THIS IS A NEW BEGINNING
WITH TECHNOLOGY ENVIRONMENTAL
MINIMAL IMPACT THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS SO I'M HOPING THAT THE
COLLEGE WOULD BE ABLE TO SERVE
AS A CATALYST TO EDUCATE THE
PEOPLE IN THE AREA. SO ON
BEHALF OF THE COLLEGE- WE'RE
DEFINITELY. WILLING AND LIKE I-
WILL RESTATE WHAT'S THE YOUR
REGULAR THIS STATE AND- WE CAME
TOGETHER ON OTHER. ON
SUPPORTING OTHER INDUSTRIES
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
ONLY COLLECTIVELY THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THIS. AND
DEFINITELY- WILL LEAN TO WORK
WITH THAT TH DEVELOPERS SOME
OF THEM HAVE ALREADY REACHED
OUT- THERE DEFINITELY-
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING A LOCAL
PREPARED WORK FORCE. AND AS I
PREVIOUSLY STATED- I'M HERE AT
YOUR SERVICE AND LOOKINGFOR TO
DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO GATHER.
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE SOCIAL AND.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT THIS
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU CAN THANK.
IF I MAY ADD- TO THAT RESPONSE-
TO THAT QUESTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS- JUST
WANTING TO POINT OUT THAT FOR
THE COMMISSION THAT HAS BEEN
EQUALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE FROM
THE DAY ONE THAT WE MET WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE MOST
PEOPLE ARE ONLY FAMILIAR WITH.
THE TYPE OF MEDIUM RECOVERY
THAT HAPPENS IN CHILE AND OTHER
PLACES THAT IS NOT AS
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY SO ONE
OF OUR PRIORITIES IS TO FROM
THE GET GO START TALKING ABOUT
THE TECHNOLOGY HOW THIS IS
DIFFERENT- JOHN IT THEN WHY
SCHOOL TALKED ABOUT HOW HIS
COMPANY IS ALREADY TO HAVING
THIS WORKSHOPS. BUT ASK THE
COMMISSION WE ARE ALSO PLANNING
TO- HAVE A WORKSHOP OUR FIRST
ONE WILL BE IN SEPTEMBER AND
THEN HAVING CONTINUING
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMMUNITY IS THREE C.
BEING- TRANSPARENT
COMMUNICATION ABOUT WHERE WE
ARE HEADING AND THE TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE TYPES OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT MAY. COME
WITH ME AT THE END. THANK YOU
FOR ADDING TO THAT I WAS GOING
TO ASK. A QUESTION AROUND THE
COMMUNITY OUT REACH- PIECE
WHICH IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
US WHICH IS WHY. THE LITHIUM
VALLEY COMMISSION WAS WAS BORN
AS AN IDEA. TO REALLY SPEARHEAD
BILLS EARLY DISCUSSIONS. AND
INFORM EDUCATE OUR ALONG WITH
THE- M. EXPERTS IN THE
INDUSTRY. TO SHARE THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND ULTIMATELY THE
COMMUNITY MAKE A- INFORMED AND
EDUCATED DECISION ON WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS IN ITS BEST
INTERESTS. AND I THINK THAT'S
THE WORK AT THE GERALD HEADER
HITTING TODAY- I'D LIKE TO JUST
ALLOW YOU TO. MAYBE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS WE'RE GOING TO BE.
GETTING CLOSE TO THE FINISH
MARKER WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS
AFTER THIS BUT- IT MAY BE A ONE
MINUTE ATTACK CLOSING STATEMENT
BY BOTH OF YOU IF. YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO ADD TO SHARE. WELL.
YES I THINK AS A SHARED IN IN
MY- PRESENTATION. I THINK THE
LEGISLATIVE- POLICY BARRIERS
AND CONSIDERATIONS ARE GOING TO
BE YOU KNOW SOME OF THE EASIER
ONES- THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
COMMISSION I THINK- WHAT IS
GOING TO REQUIRE INTENTIONALITY
AND THE TENSION IS HAVING THAT
DIALOGUE WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT OUTSIDE
OF THE ENVIRONMENT OUTSIDE OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
THE- THIS NEW INDUSTRY THERE'S
ALSO. A HUGE CONCERN ABOUT
BENEFITS STATE AND LOCAL ABOUT
PREPARING OUR REGION AND- IN
THE INTEGRATION OF THE TRIBE
SIX OF INSURING THAT ALL OF OUR
LOCAL POPULATIONS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACCESS TO THE
NEW JOBS- THAT CAN BE CREATED.
AGAIN SO. THAT'S MY DAD- TAKING
CLASS- BUT IT'S AGAIN IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO DO THIS
HAND IN HAND WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND THAT WE CAN DEMONSTRATE
EARLY- NOT JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT
WILL BE BUT EARLY DEMONSTRATE
HOW WE ARE GOING TO BE
INCLUDING THEM IN THE THOUGHT
PROCESS AND AS PARTNERS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR. THANK YOU
MISSUS BOSS I LOOK FORWARD TO
MEETING YOU AND IF THERE'S ANY
WAY THAT WE COULD SUPPORT YOU
PLEASE PLEASE DO NOT HESITATE
TO REACH OUT. MY RECOMMENDATION
TO THE COMMITTEE IS THAT AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD AND MAKE DECISIONS
PLEASE. INCLUDE US COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE SERVING ABOUT TWO
MILLION STUDENTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
NIMBLE- WHEN IT COMES TO
CREATING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TAILORED TO THE NEEDS. OF
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES. WE'RE HERE
WE'RE COMMITTED AND WE'RE
EXCITED AND WE LOOK FORWARD. TO
CONTRACTING TRIBUTE AND ANYWAY
TO THE SUCCESS OF THIS INDUSTRY
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU DR ENOUGH AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GOING TO CHECK TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY CALLS LINED
UP MODERATOR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
I'M ALSO GOING TO. ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WISHES TO SPEAK-
DURING THIS- SAID SHIN OF THE
AGENDA. I'M GOING TO ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
TELECONFERENCE ROOMS- THAT
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THREE NINE AND THEN I
WILL ASK AGAIN THE MODERATOR TO
SEE IF ANYONE IS LINED UP TO
SPEAK FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS VIA
TELEPHONE LINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TO WIN Q.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU. MY PLEASURE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE FIRST
WATER LINE WILL ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MODERATOR MISTER CHAIRED.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY
SMITH CHAIR OF THE HALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL- YOU KNOW.
CAUGHT THE END OF THE COMMENT
YEAR ABOUT PRE APPRENTICESHIP
AND WORKFORCE LOAN I WANTED TO
ENCOURAGE LOCAL LEADERS AND-
AND THE BUSINESSES WHO ARE ON
THE AGENDA TODAY WHO. WHO I'M
LOOKING INTO INTO THIS
INDUSTRY- TO WORK WITH THE
IMPERIAL IMPERIAL IN TRADE
COUNCIL- ON YEAH PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT ARE CLEARLY WORKFORCE
WE MET- IN PRE APPRENTICESHIP
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS ARE THE-
L. A. R. C. W. A. CAN
ABSOLUTELY. HELP THE FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP IN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS- BUT OUR- OUR PROGRAMS
THAT ARE DOWN THERE NOW IN THE
AREA STATE AND READY TO WORK
WITH THE INDUSTRY. ON THIS
PROJECT OR PROJECTS LIKE THIS
SAID THE MOVES FORWARD- TO RAMP
UP- TRAINING INTO HAVE- WORKERS
LOCAL WORKERS READY TO WORK ON
A PROJECT SUCH AS THIS- AT THE
BEGINNING COME TO FRUITION SO
WE THINK THAT COMMITTEES. IN
THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS TIME
TODAY TO. SHED LIGHT ON THIS
ISSUE- WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
PARTNERS. IN THE AREA- IF
SOMETHING SHOULD MOVE FORWARD-
IN THIS IN THIS AREA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE MINDING THE WHOLE
SECOND MONARCH REPRESENTED THE
SUBSEA ACCORDING. CREATED IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE ESTANCIA
QUALITY THE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
WORKING IN CONSULTATION. AND
COOPERATION WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO OVERSEE THE
COMPREHENSIVE RESTORATION OF.
MEMBERS INCLUDE RIVERSIDE
IMPERIAL COUNTY INTERNAL
RADIATION DISTRICT COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND A
PART OF MARTINEZ. DOESN'T
PROBABLY NINETY. AUTHORITY HAS
FOUGHT TO LOW LEADERS ROLE IN
REVIVAL FOR THE SAME CLEAN
KNOWLEDGE DEPRIVE THAT IS B.
THAT SHE- WORKING WITH FEDERAL
STATE. THANK SINGLE PERSON
LEADERSHIP AND THE CHRISTIAN.
CARE ENERGY COMMISSION.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND GO BUSINESS
POINT OF THE SO TAKE THESE
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES. WE
WOULD LIKE TO REPORT THE
COMMONS CONVEYED BY THE STATE'S
ABILITY AND COMMISSION CHANGED
IN THE PAST. REGARDING THE
ADVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS OF THE
SOUNDS THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES WILL BE BEARING AND
THE NEED FOR THE STATE TO DO
ALL IT CAN. TO RESPONSIBILITY
ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE
SEASON RECEDING SHORELINES. ON
THAT NOTE WE WANTED TO
COMMUNICATE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADOPTION OF THE SALT SEA
RESTORATION FUND THAT COULD BE
SUPPORTED BY GEOTHERMAL AND LET
HIM PRODUCTION ROYALTIES. TO
HELP BRIDGE THE SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING GAP NEEDED TO ENSURE
THE FULL SPECTRUM OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SPECIES MITIGATION
NEEDS FOR THE STATE. LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION AND FUTURE AREAS OF
STANDING READY TO ASSIST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
THOSE COMMENTS NEXT CALL. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN NUMBER ONE FIFTH
THREE OF A REMINDER LADIES AND
IF YOU TO MAKE A COMMENT YOU
MADE ONE ZERO ACTIVE TIME. ONE
ONE TWO THREE YEAR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S. SO MADAM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COOLEY DESTINY
COLIN RYAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE BECAUSE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION WITH OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OPERATING IN THE
SOLVENCY REGION. I ALSO SERVE
AS A- COMMISSION ON TAKING
COMMISSION MEMBER AND WE
REPRESENTING THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY STREET- COUNTY IS ONE
OF THE PREMIER CENTERS FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AND THE VALLEY IS HOME TO TWO
MAJOR PORTS. HI THE SUPPORT AND
THE WESTPORT- WHICH ARE YOU
KNOW SERVING NEARLY ALL THE
INTERNATIONAL TRUCK TRAFFIC
CROSSING THE BUTTE COUNTY WITH
THE TOTAL TRADE VALUE OVER
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION IT
ALSO EXPERIENCES- BORDER
CROSSING SO ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION VEHICLES CROSSING THEM
IN BOTH DIRECTIONS BECAUSE OF
BOTH THE COMBINED. BOTH NORTH
AND SOUTH WITH IDOLING TIMES A
ONE TO SIX HOURSADDING
CONSIDERABLE GREENHOUSE GASES
TO CALIFORNIA'S INVENTORY OF
WHICH CALIFORNIA AND HE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
PERSISTENTLY IGNORED ANY CARE
ABOUT THE ALSO RANKS AMONG THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
WITH AN AVERAGE OF 20%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND THESE
CONDITIONS IMPACT THE ENTIRE
SALTON SEA REGION FROM IMPAIR
THE COACHELLA VALLEY. I DO
WANNA PLUG THE EFFORTS OF JAIL
BOTH THE GOVERNMENT
CALIFORNIANS AND UNITED BY AN
ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN- FOR THEIR IN-
COMMITMENT TO OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT. BUT THAT SHOULD
MIND THAT. WE DON'T HAVE. THIS
ADVANCE COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE
IN THE COURSE AREA YOU KNOW
MOST OF THESE COMMUNITIES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- LIVE
IN ECONOMICALLY DEPRESSED AREAS
AGRICULTURAL AREAS- LARGEST
CITIES INNER CITIES. SO RELY ON
A SINGLE STRATEGY AND
EXPLOITATION FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES OF OUR REGION COULD
POTENTIALLY EXACERBATE PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS CAN THE
DISADVANTAGED AREAS OF THE SONG
C. SO. THEY NEED TO BE A
COHERENT CHANGE THROUGHOUT THE
REGION WE ARE SHIFTING. THE
RESOURCE THE SOURCE OF ENERGY
THEY INDUSTRY OPERATES. WE ARE
THE STATE OF BEING GIVEN A
BLACK CAMPUS BLANK CANVAS THAT
OPENS UP A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR COLLABORATION TO SET NEW
STANDARDS. OF HOW THE EMERGING
LET HIM INDUSTRY OPERATES
ACROSS THE NATION PERHAPS THE
WORLD'S. AND COMMUNITIES
PERSPECTIVE ENVISIONED HAVE TO
BE CONSIDERED. INTO A SHE REAL
CARBON REDUCTION GOALS AND
EQUITABLE USE OF NATURAL
RESOURCES. OUR REGION IS RICH
IN NATURAL RESOURCE AND IT HAS
A STRONG WORKFORCE IN ITS
REGION ITS CULTURE YET THE
COMMUNITY RESPONSE HE HAS NOT
BEEN A TRUE BENEFICIARY OF
EXPLOITED RESOURCES. THEY HAVE
BEEN FACED WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION OF THE REGION
DEALING WITH HEALTH ISSUES
SEEING AN ENVIRONMENTAL-
DEGRADATION AND IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS INCREASE
EXPONENTIALLY AS WE CONTINUE TO
ADD ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF
POLLUTION THAT CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE EXISTING POOR
AIR QUALITY. WE EXPERIENCED A
FRENZY A WIN BY- FEEL SOLAR
ENERGY IN FACT WE WENT
BACKWARDS IN A WAY AGRICULTURAL
LAND THAT HAS PROVIDED JOBS
LOCALLY FOR FARMWORKERS AND
OTHERS IN THE INDUSTRY FOR OVER
A HUNDRED YEARS. INTRADE FOR
SOLAR INSTALLATIONS THAT
PRODUCE ALMOST SEE LOCAL JOBS
AND DEFINITELY NO LONG TERM
JOBS- THE DEVELOPMENT AND
CREATION OF NEW INDUSTRY MATHIS
HAVE TO CONSIDER ITS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE IMMEDIATE
COMMUNITY THE ECONOMIC DRIVER
THAT IS MOVING THE USE OF
LITHIUM BONTA SAUCY SHOULD ALSO
DRIVE THE ECONOMIC GROWTH OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE REGION. INCENTIVIZING THE
CREATION OF LOCAL WORKFORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY.
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT
BERMAN- JUST TO STAKEHOLDERS
POLICY MAKERS AND LET HIM
PRODUCES CAN WORK HAND IN HAND
I BELIEVE CIRCUMVENT IN
THE ECOSYSTEM AND THE PUBLIC'S
WELLBEING CAN RESULT IN GOOD
INTENTIONS YIELDING BAD
OUTCOMES. AS A MEMBER OF THE
TEAM COMMISSION MYSELF
REPRESENTING THIS ADVANCE
COMMUNITIES I WILL BE IT IT
WILL BE MY DUTY TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND TO DO SO
DILIGENTLY AND WHAT DO SO BY
SHOWING THE COMMUNITY VOICES
ALWAYS FRONT AND CENTER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU OUR MODERATOR
ANY OTHER CALLS. YES WE HAVE TO
IN Q. HELLO ONE SIXTY ONE- LINE
IS A- GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TAKING MY MANY IS
JAMES RODRIGUEZ AYE A LIVING
CATELLA. AND THE REASON THAT I
DECIDED TO GIVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT IS TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF A- GENERAL- AVERAGE
CITIZENS PERSPECTIVE AND TAKE
ON HOW THIS CAN ACTUALLY
BENEFIT OUR LOCAL AREA- MANY OF
THE OTHER CALLERS HAVE. MADE A
VERY VALID POINTS ON THE FACTS
THAT THE AREA NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO BENEFIT FINANCIALLY-
ECONOMICALLY- AND- NOT ONLY
JUST WITH- AREAS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE BRINGING IN MORE. JOBS
AND MORE SOCIAL EQUITY BY THE
ACCESS TO THE ACTUAL A PRODUCT
SO THE BIGGEST THING THAT
LITHIUM CAN BE USED FOR IS
STORAGE- ENERGY STORAGE WHICH
IS FOR BATTERIES. SO I WOULD-
SUSPECTING HOPE THAT ONE OF THE
MAIN GOALS WOULD BE TO PROVIDE-
AND SHE LOOKED AND- STORAGE. AS
WELL- SO IF THESE PROVIDERS ARE
GONNA BE COMING IN AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE USING OUR AREA AND
OUR SOCIAL- MEMBERS TO TRY TO
CREATE A BUSINESS AND TO.
BETTER THE SALTON SEA WHICH IS
A GREAT GOAL- BECAUSE THAT HAS
BEEN CONTRIBUTING. A THEN- IT
SHOULD ALSO BENEFIT THE LOCAL
AREAS BECAUSE ONE OF THE MAJOR
THINGS THAT WERE ALSO SEEN THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND LOCAL
SENATORS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
GET. A PASS TO THE- OUTAGES OF
WATER OR IF FOR ELECTRICITY SO-
IT SHOULD EXTEND FURTHER THAN
JUST WANTING TO BRING THESE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN TO WORK ON
THE PROJECT. BUT TO BOLSTER THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY'RE LIVING
IN AND TO MAKE IT MORE SELF
SUSTAINING SO THAT THAT GEO
THERMAL ENERGY THE WATER THAT'S
BEING DESALINATED AND BE
CLICKING ON THAT THE ACTUALLY
BEING EXTRACTED CAN BE PUT TO
USE IN THIS AREA NOT JUST
EXPORTED OUT OF THE AREA-
THAT'S THE ONLY THING. THAT I
CAN THINK OF BY LISTENING TO
ALL OF THESE CONVERSATIONS AND-
TYPES OF- OF THE TAKES THAT- A
REGULAR AVERAGE PERSON MIGHT
NOT LISTEN TO THE- A LONG.
DETAILED EXPLANATION AND THAT'S
KIND OF THE- GENERAL IDEA THAT
I TOOK FROM WHAT IS GOING TO BE
HAPPENING BRING IN A NEW
INDUSTRY THAT WILL HOPEFULLY.
HELP TO GENERATE THE CLEANING
UP OF THE SALTON SEA WHICH IS.
ALREADY NEEDED- AND TO
SPEARHEAD GEO THIRD ENERGY AS
WELL IN THE AREA WHICH I'VE
ALREADY KNOWN ABOUT FOR
PROBABLY THE LAST DECADE-
BECAUSE- A LOCAL COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO GET GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY ACTIVE IN THE HALL AREAS
SO- I THINK THAT THIS IS A
GREAT. WAY TO INTRODUCE THE
PUBLIC TO IT- BUT IT NEEDS TO
BE MORE ON LAYMAN'S TERMS-
BECAUSE THE BIG INDICATORS WERE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS AND
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. BUT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IT IN A LAYMAN'S
TERMS PERSPECTIVE- THIS IS HOW
IT CAN BENEFIT US THIS IS WHAT
THESE COMPANIES HAVE. PROMISED
TO. WE WILL BRING TO THE AIR TO
BE. THE A- THIS IS HOW MUCH IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BENEFITS THE
AIR NOT JUST JOBS BECAUSE AS WE
ALL KNOW WITH PAST. MANY
COMPANIES WILL. TO GET RID OF
PAYING JOBS TO KEEP THE HIGH
PAYING- CORPORATES OR- MORE
PROPER COMING IN SO CHOI IS ONE
SMALL FACTOR OF THIS IT NEEDS
TO ACTUALLY ENRICH THE
COMMUNITY. SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE
TO SAY THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS- NEXT WEEK- ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GARCIA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ONE ONE MARTINEZ SOME AFTER THE
GEISHA DISTRICT ARE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE CHERRY
AND FOR THE INTO THE ISSUE YEAH-
I THE ABOUT UP ON UTILITY- SIR
ENERGY TO SERVER SIDE COUNTY
AND IMPERIL. HOW WE ARE ALSO
CURRENTLY. ON YOU TECHNOLOGY TO
PORTABLE ENERGY RESOURCE. AND
OUR COULD FOR JENNA AND
STRENGTHENING POWER DELIVERY
SYSTEM ALL WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME CARING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT- WITH THAT BEING
SAID WE THINK THAT THE ADVENT
OF LITHIUM- CAN THAT WE CAN
TRIGGER ARE MOVING A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT CONVERGED IN AND
AROUND THE SALTON SEA-
DISCUSSED IN THE PANELS- THAT
EARLIER TODAY AND THERE ARE
MULTI BENEFITS RELATED TO- THE-
R. P. S. GOALS IN THE CZECH.
REDUCING THE PRICE AND YIELD
THERMAL ENERGY WHICH IS A FORM
AND- RESOURCE SECTORS IMPORTANT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD- ALSO WITH
THE- ADVENT OF G. H. REDUCTION
AND ELECTRIFICATION OVER
SECTOR- AND BATTERIES- IN
ADDITION TO OUR THE SEED
RECEIVES OF BEING ABLE TO
CONVERGE AROUND AGRICULTURE
AUDIO THERMAL PRODUCTION AND
LIFT THEM TO OUR- ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE AT LAST BEGINNING
DOES. MITIGATION EVENTS THAT
HAPPEN AROUND THE SALT SEA SO
WE ARE SUPPORT ON END OF
WORKING WE YOU IN THE AND STAKE
TO ENSURE THAT WE THE BENEFITS
AND WE BALLPARK ABOUT HERE TO
WITH THE THIS IS A ARE. FOR THE
STATE OF PA. WHICH IS- ALSO
BEING ALIGNED WITH THE EFFORTS
OF THE FEDERAL TO WITH MAKE.
HIM CRITICAL MEMORIES- SO JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
ARE THE RECORD- AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR- I COMMITTEE
ECONOMIC THE CC PC AND ALL THE
LOCAL COMMITTEE STATE TO PLAYED
A ROLE IN. PUSHING THE IMPORT
ISSUE FOR SO FAR. SIX TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THEY'VE TAKEN
THEMSELVES OUT OF Q. ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU KAREN KIDDING- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME AND RUBIO THAT
I AND I'M PART OF THE TO WRITE
IN ON PROFIT ORGANIZATION.
EIGHT A FUTURE WALK TELL VALLEY
FAMILY. HEALTHY STABLE THRIVING
THROUGH HOW AND I CAN STABILITY.
I'M NOT GOING THAT THE INQUIRY-
WILL COME INTO FOCUS PEAKING
HOW PROVIDE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
ON THE DETAIL IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY AND IMPERIAL VALUE TO
THE CREATION OF JOBS. AND
YOU'LL THURMOND THE COMMITTEES
AND BATTERY MANUFACTURING PLANT
DEPENDENCY CAN BE AN AVENUE TO
HELP WITH THE BROKEN TV
STRAIGHT RESTORATION WHICH IS
EVERY DAY HI COMMUNITIES AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
ADDRESS IT. ON IT IS AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
TRANSFORM LIABILITY- CONFIRMING
LIABILITY COPPER COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ONE SIXTY THREE LINE OF OPEN.
YOU HAVE TO SHARE AND- CAN YOU
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS. THE LARGE-
AND I A RESIDENT OF THE EASTERN
OF A THE I AM CALLING BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN INFORMED OF THE THIS
RESTORATION PLAN AND I WAS
VERY. INTERESTED IN LEARNING
MORE ABOUT IT AS I HAVE-
GROWING UP IN IN VERMONT AND
RIGHT NEXT TO STOP AND SEE- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
DISCUSSION HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
ABOUT ABOUT YOU KNOW GREAT
RESTORING OURSELVES IN C. M.
BRING ABOUT BENEFITS TO THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. OF THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT LIVE
AROUND THE SALTON SEA ARE THE
ONES THAT ANGER- THROUGHOUT.
THE YEARS YOU KNOW SOMEONE LET
CONDITIONS IN A BAG OF BY THE
BUMP AND SEE- SO I REALLY HOPE
THAT YOU KNOW FOR THE ALONG THE
LINES WE CAN. COMPEL PROPEL
FURTHER- LONG TERM OUTCOMES FOR
THE RESIDENTS OF THE CONTROL OF
THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
AND AT THE SAME TIME BRING
ABOUT OUR ECONOMIC- CREATION SO.
TO OUR VALUE. THANK YOU. MY
SIXTY FOR YOUR MIND NOW OPEN-
GOOD AFTERNOON AND SHARING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HONEY AND
I'M CALLING AS A RESIDENTS OF
THE EASTERN SUCH A LOVELY- I AM
CALLING IN TOTAL. THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT IN THE PROCESS BUT
IF YOU DON'T RECOVERY AT THE
SALTON SEA CURRENT HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER COULD NOT COULD NOT
MAKE MY LOOK BAD ON THIS
OCCASION- LEN IMPERIAL
VALLEY'S. THROUGH THE CREATION
OF JOBS IN YOUR TERM OFFICES OF
SPECULATING BUT THE TROLLEY.
AND BATTERY MONEY FACTORING M.
BATTERY MANUFACTURING PLANTS
THIS INDUSTRY CAN BE AN AVENUE
TO HAUL WHICH ALSO SEE A
RESTORATION WHICH IS EVERYDAY.
HARMING OUR COMMUNITY MORE. ALL
WE CAN TO MAKE WE CAN TRANSFORM
A LIABILITY IN ARE NOT TWENTY
TWO HOPPER COME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALL AND A THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE. MY
APOLOGIES AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU MUCH WE ARE PASSED. TIME
THAT- WE WERE GIVEN FOR THE
HEARING I'M GLAD THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE EVERYONE'S CALL.
MUSCLE HAPPY TO SEE THE
ENGAGEMENT FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING UP WITH
THE SECOND HEARING ON THE
MATTER. BEGIN TO. HONE IN ON
THE SUBJECT AREA FOR THAT
HEARING. I WANT TO JUST- THANK
ALL OF THE PANELISTS- THAT WERE
WITH US TODAY THEY PAY AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ROLE. NOT
JUST FOR TODAY'S DISCUSSION BUT
MOVING FORWARD. IN THEIR
CAPACITIES. AND HELPING US
CONNECT THE DOTS. ON THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. THE COUNTRY.
OUR STATE AND THIS VERY
IMPORTANT REGION. THAT I AM
HONORED TO REPRESENT. AND
THAT'S- THE LITTLE VALLEY
REGION. IMPERIAL EASTERN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. I WANTED JUST
TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE SPEAKER FOR- SANCTIONING-
THIS HEARING. AND AND HIS TEAM
FOR HELPING TO SHAPE. THE
AGENDA. OF BIG THANK YOU TO OUR
TEAM. LEAN AMOUNT OVER A WHOLE
SAYS SUCH AS ME GOVERNMENTAL
AUTO TO SUBDIVIDE. FOR WORKING
ON. BRINGING THIS ALL TOGETHER.
THANK YOU AGAIN EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED. AND AT THIS TIME
WE WILL RETURN.